voilà monsieur le Président de la
République mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues je redis ce que
ce que j'ai dit ce matin après 150
heures d'audition après avoir reçu 88
auditionnés après avoir reçu le plus de
5000 pages de contribution écrite notre
commission d'enquête visant établir les
raisons de la perte de souveraineté
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
termine aujourd'hui sont ces cycles
d'audition avec votre audition monsieur
le Président de la République nous avons
donc le privilège de vous accueillir
pour clore ce cycle après avoir reçu
votre prédécesseur ce matin et je tiens
très sincèrement à vous remercier
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation de
vous entretenir avec les députés sur les
orientations de la politique énergétique
définie au cours de votre mandat
je tiens personnellement et au nom de
tous les membres de la commission
d'enquête à vous en remercier car il
s'agit en effet d'un précédent dans les
procédures de commission d'enquête en
tout cas au cours de la cinquième
République c'est la première fois que
des présidents de la République viennent
s'exprimer devant notre commission je
tiens à souligner trois caractères que
cette décision que vous avez prise
traduit d'abord votre attachement à
l'institution parlementaire
ensuite l'importance que vous accordez à
la situation énergétique de la France
dans les implications sont à la fois
sociales économiques et géostratégique
et enfin la reconnaissance de la
légitimité de l'intervention du
Parlement dans le domaine de la
politique énergétique notamment dans le
cadre de nos activités d'évaluation et
de contrôle
voilà donc monsieur le Président de la
République notre commission à l'honneur
de vous accueillir monsieur le Président
nous vous remercions encore une fois
d'avoir répondu favorablement votre
invitation et comme je l'ai indiqué ce
matin en guise d'introduction le fait de
recevoir deux anciens présidents de la
République démontre bien à quel point ce
sujet est aujourd'hui au cœur de nos
débats Monsieur François Hollande vous
avez été président de la République de
2012 à 2017 et vous avez à la fois
incité ou renforcement des compétences
et de l'information du Parlement dans le
domaine de l'énergie avec le
développement de nouveaux outils de
programmation
issus notamment de la loi de 2015
relative à la transition écologique et
pour la croissance verte la stratégie
nationale bas carbone et la
programmation plus régnelle de l'énergie
éveillée au cours de votre mandat à
l'affaiblissement de la démocratie
participative par une ordonnance de 2016
ratifiée en 2018
faute de temps nous ne sommes pas allés
au fond de cette problématique comme
d'autres d'ailleurs puisque le spectre
de nos travaux a déjà été très large
nous avons auditionné plusieurs membres
des gouvernements constitués lors de
votre mandat présidentiel Monsieur
Manuel Valls madame Delphine bateau
Monsieur Arnaud Montebourg madame
Ségolène Royal pour ne parler que des
ministres plusieurs chefs d'entreprise
ou responsables d'organismes nommés au
cours de cette période ont également été
entendus à l'occasion de nos travaux je
pense à Messieurs Jean-Bernard Lévy
Philippe knoreux Bernard Fontana
Jean-Christophe Niel Pierre-Marie Abadie
Daniel werberg Yves Brechet ou Monsieur
François Brotte au cours des auditions
parmi les mesures relevant de la
politique énergétique durant votre
mandat la loi de 2015 relative à la
transition écologique et pour la
croissance verte a retenu
particulièrement notre attention et
parmi les 215 articles de cette loi deux
dispositions ont fait l'objet de
diverses commentaires la réduction de la
part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique à 50% à l'horizon 2025 ainsi
que le plafonnement de la puissance
nucléaire installée à 63,2 gigawatts
mais d'autres actions mises en oeuvre au
cours de votre mandat ont également été
évacués évoquer pardon excusez-moi la
cop21 évidemment les mécanismes de
capacité et d'effacement le déploiement
des compteurs intelligents les fonds
chaleurs et le financement de la
transition énergétique ou de manière
peut-être plus abusive le barrage de
silence
l'accord électoral passé avec les verres
a également fait l'objet de divers
commentaires nous savons cependant
monsieur le Président que les
responsabilités qui incombent un chef
d'État et les votes ont été
particulièrement lourdes avec les
attentats sur notre territoire la
gestion de la dette grecque les
interventions militaires extérieures ou
le brexit ne peuvent s'encombrer de
batailles de chiffres dont la porte est
normative est d'ailleurs discutable d'un
point de vue pratique ces annonces de
réduction voire de fermeture aurait
néanmoins des mobilisés une filière
entière je ne doute pas que vous
reviendrez sur le sujet nous avons exclu
le domaine militaire de notre champ
d'investigation mais les auditions ont
clairement mises en évidence que
l'énergie est utilisée comme une arme ou
conçue comme un moyen d'hégémonie par
divers états trois d'entre eux ont fait
l'objet d'observation au cours de nos
travaux la Chine l'Allemagne la Russie
pour ne parler que des plus intéressants
c'est important en tout cas c'est
pourquoi il nous a paru nécessaire
d'entendre votre point de vue et encore
une fois nous vous remercions de votre
disponibilité
voilà monsieur le Président de la
République je vous donne donc la parole
pour un pro pour introductif puis si
vous y consentez nous organiserons un
tour de question-Réponses dans un format
que vous avez souhaité le plus
interactif possible il me semble merci
encore de votre disponibilité bien
monsieur le Président sur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les députés je vous
remercie pour votre invitation même si
vous avez choisi une date
où l'objet de votre commission ne va pas
forcément être le sujet principal de la
journée
et je le regrette parce que les choix
énergétiques sont essentiels pour
l'avenir de notre pays et je ne te l'ai
donc dans le cadre de votre commission
d'enquête et avec l'attachement que j'ai
pour le Parlement à venir au temps qu'il
était possible non seulement
répondre à vos questions mais donner un
certain nombre de clarifications sur
l'action que j'ai pu engager à la tête
de notre pays
je disais que c'était une évidence
aujourd'hui parce que la guerre en
Ukraine
qui a été déclenché donc en février
2022 a fait ressurgir le spectre de la
pénurie liée à la fin des
approvisionnements en gaz venant de la
Russie
et la crainte d'une flambée des prix de
l'électricité puisqu'ils sont indexés
chacun le sait sur ceux du gaz alors que
parallèlement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vous avez
évoqué l'accord de Paris La Coop 21 nous
oblige à accélérer la transition
énergétique vers donc ce qu'on appelle
les énergies non carbonées
face à ce triple défi des filles de
répondre aux besoins éviter la pénurie
des filles des prix dans un contexte
d'inflation des filles du climat qui
menacent et on le voit bien notre
planète les enjeux d'indépendance de
souveraineté et de sécurité sont
essentielles
et dans ce contexte le nucléaire est
avec les énergies renouvelables et la
sobriété énergétique l'une des réponses
les plus appropriées pour se débarrasser
des énergies fossiles et pour répondre
aux besoins de la population
nous ne traiterons pas de l'énergie
nucléaire à des fins militaires même si
l'on sait bien que dans la recherche il
y a des liens très profonds qui unissent
ce que les ingénieurs font pour
améliorer notre capacité de production
d'électricité mais aussi pour rendre
notre force de dissuasion crédible mais
tel n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un
moment où les besoins en électricité ont
été exprimés avec le plus d'intensité
compte tenu de ce qui se produisait en
Ukraine
que notre production nucléaire a été la
plus faible de ces 30 dernières années
279 térawatts
a connu une année noire avec une perte
de 18 milliards d'euros et une dette qui
a doublé pour atteindre 60 milliards
d'euros
la question vous l'avez posée
et elle se pose chez chacun de nos
compatriotes c'est que s'est-il donc
passé
et c'est pour répondre précisément à
cette interrogation que votre commission
d'enquête s'est constituée pour
identifier les causes d'une telle
situation
en remontant aussi loin que possible
dans le temps
comme dans l'échelle des responsabilités
je vais donc aborder la problématique la
plus actuelle avant de revenir sur la
période relative à mon mandat aux
engagements que j'avais présenté comme
candidat et aux décisions que j'ai
prises comme président
comment d'abord expliquer la chute de la
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire depuis deux ans
en 2022 cette production je l'ai rappelé
est tombée à 279 térats durant tout le
mandat qui fut le mien elle a dépassé
400 terawatts avec même un pic en 2018
2015 pardon de 420 térats
est-ce un défaut d'investissement
dans le passé qui expliquerait l'arrêt
momentané
de près de 26 réacteurs sur 56
est-ce un doute sur la pertinence du
nucléaire lié à une décision législative
ou à une posture politique voire même un
accord électoral
est-ce du un manque de personnel au sein
d'EDF faute de recrutement
d'ingénieur de techniciens est-ce la
fermeture de Fessenheim non 4 fois non
il est établi je pense que votre
commission à tous toutes les données il
a été établi que la cause de cette
réduction de capacité a été provoquée
par la découverte d'un phénomène
de corrosion sous contrainte
de fissures
certaines de quelques millimètres
d'autres plus graves encore et notamment
sur des contrats sur des centrales
récentes ce qui est plus inquiétant
encore
un accident industriel qui est venu
s'ajouter au lourds programme de
maintenance qui avait été lancé
et qui était prévu de longue date et qui
a pu être même reporter compte tenu de
la crise sanitaire
d'autres incidents viennent d'être
révélés comme la fatigue thermique à
Polly 2 ou à kattenham 3 qui obligera
EDF a présenté dans les meilleurs délais
un programme de révision de toutes les
centrales à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire
ainsi le phénomène des corrosion et des
fissures de résultats d'un manque
d'entretien
d'un sous-investissement
d'une défiance à l'égard de la filière
d'une insuffisance de personnel
mais
s'explique par une conception même des
centrales
historique ou de travaux de réparation
qui ont été effectués il y a bien
longtemps sur des éléments de tuyauterie
et qui révèlent aujourd'hui de possibles
soyons prudents et ne laissons pas de
doute des défaillances dont il sera
nécessaire de savoir l'ampleur
il était donc légitime et indispensable
que EDF même si ça représentait pour
cette entreprise à coup
que des centrales puissent être
momentanément arrêtés
la baisse de production d'électricité
nucléaire en 2021 et 2022 et donc en
aucune manière la conséquence d'une
décision politique
ou de l'aménagement ou d'un arrangement
électoral remontant à plus de 10 ans
pas davantage d'un désintérêt à l'égard
d'une filière qui je le rappelle est
essentielle pour notre pays non la
baisse de la production d'électricité
alors même que nous en avions le plus
besoin résulte d'une addition
d'incidence d'incident dans un contexte
où et c'est indispensable une vigilance
est exigée et une autorité de sûreté
veille pour prodiguer des avis et
obliger à des arrêts
et pourtant il a été pour certains
tentants
mais comment les empêcher de faire des
polémiques député cette situation
a des choix politiques remontant à plus
de 10 ans
rappelons que EDF a perdu à cause des
arrêts donc je viens de parler une
capacité de production par rapport à ce
qui était le volume que durant mon
mandat nous étions capables avec EDF
cette EDF qu'il est produit une
perte donc de production de 130 TW
faisceadam je le rappelle puisque c'est
souvent évoqué n'en produisait autant de
son activité que de 10 à 12 TER
un dixième de ce que
hélas les arrêts ont souligné comme
manquement
alors une confusion a été délibérément
entretenue comme si les pannes arrêtent
incident corrosion maintenant
relevée d'une défiance à l'égard du
nucléaire et bien je dirais exactement
l'inverse c'est parce qu'il y a des
difficultés dans la filière nucléaire
c'est parce que précisément elle fait
face et on pouvait d'ailleurs
l'anticiper
cet état c'était d'ailleurs le sens à la
fois du grand carénage et de la
politique de maintenance qu'elle fait
face à un certain nombre de réparations
qui sont nécessaires ou de vigilance qui
doivent être accrues par rapport à des
incidences c'est parce que la filière
est dans cette situation
que nous devons la défendre et c'est ce
que j'ai fait tout au long de mon mandat
défendre la filière nucléaire tout en
souhaitant voulant travaillant pour que
elle puisse être complétée par une
montée des énergies renouvelables la
deuxième question que je voulais évoquer
pour rester sur la problématique
actuelle c'est comment comprendre la
situation particulièrement préoccupante
d'EDF en 2022 et 2023
alors que de 2012 à 2019 c'est à dire
large partie de mon mandat EDF avait
dégagé en moyenne 4 milliards d'euros de
résultat par an
malgré un prix de l'énergie plutôt bas
aujourd'hui EDF affiche une perte de 18
milliards d'euros et une dette je l'ai
dit de plus de 60 milliards 65
exactement
alors là aussi posons-nous la question
est-ce que cette situation financière
extrêmement délicate et la conséquence
de choix de décision qui aurait été
défavorables à la filière nucléaire ces
dernières années où
à cause de cette affichage d'un mix à
50% ou même à cause de la fermeture de
Fessenheim
chacun sait ici que non
c'est la résultante de la baisse de la
disponibilité du parc de centrale qui
n'a pas pu fournir les 400 terawatths
que jusqu'à présent elle était capable
de dégager mais seulement 279 de la
diminution de la production hydraulique
à cause de la sécheresse à laquelle
c'est ajouté la décision gouvernementale
de relever le volume de la reine ici
chacun connaît ce procédé et cette
mécanique relevant le relèvement de 20
terawatts par rapport au sang que EDF
doit fournir assez concurrents à
infliger une perte de 8 milliards
d'euros à l'entreprise et fourni aux
concurrents sans qu'ils y ait sans qu'il
y ait eu la moindre capacité de
production supplémentaire une
un super profit qui fait que ses
concurrents peuvent revendre 10 fois
plus cher l'électricité qu'ils ont
acheté à EDF
ce coût supplémentaire lié à ce
déplafonnement dans le cadre d'une
mécanique sur laquelle beaucoup sont
revenus pour la critiquer la reine n'a
pas été compensée par l'État et donc
c'est EDF qui a été affaibli
délibérément par cette décision
pour les années qui viennent d'ailleurs
si ce dispositif de la reine n'était pas
corrigé
alors que la production d'électricité
nucléaire ne pourra pas retrouver
rapidement son niveau antérieur contenu
des travaux qui vont être qui vont être
qu'il va être nécessaire d'exécuter
suite aux incidents que j'ai rappelé eDF
va être confronté à de nouveaux
résultats négatifs sur le plan financier
et c'est à ce moment-là que l'on peut se
poser la question de l'avenir de la
filière nucléaire et c'est pourquoi
votre commission d'enquête est si
importante
pourra-t-elle EDF assumer seul la
poursuite du programme qu'on appelle
grand carénage pour prolonger la durée
des centrales le lancement des opère 2
à peu près 50 milliards le grand
carénage étant évalué à 33 milliards
l'achèvement de Flamanville
sans oublier les investissements dans
les renouvelables et les réseaux
la nationalisation d'EDF
car je rappelle que EDF avait été
privatisé
vous retrouverez par qui donc la
relationnalisation d'EDF n'a de sens que
si elle débouche sur une
recapitalisation de l'entreprise une
recapitalisation d'ailleurs
substantielle et par une mobilisation
cynique virtative de l'épargne
disponible pour financer précisément les
masses d'investissement qui sont devant
nous
voilà ce que je voulais dire pour
expliquer la situation actuelle je vais
maintenant revenir c'est tout à fait
nécessaire à la fois sur les engagements
que j'avais pris comme candidat et les
choix qui furent les miens comme
président
donc je vais vous plonger dans
l'histoire l'histoire récente et qui est
encore dans tous les esprits donc en
élection présidentielle je rappelle a eu
lieu en 2012 se trouve que 2011 est
avant 2012 ce que votre commission aux
enquête ne manquera pas d'établir donc
en 2011 mars 2011
produit une catastrophe Fukushima qui
c'est vrai est un tsunami et pas un
accident nucléaire elle tsunami qui
néanmoins crée un doute dans la mesure
où une centrale nucléaire et concernée
dans le périmètre
c'est un événement mondial et qui
produit forcément un choc qui va d'abord
frapper le Japon travers de nombreuses
victimes et conduire le gouvernement
japonais a annoncé la fermeture de
toutes les centrales nucléaires du pays
quelques semaines ou mois qui suivent
après la catastrophe l'Allemagne
l'Italie la Belgique
annonce leur sortie du nucléaire dans un
délai plus ou moins long
il est vrai aussi que parallèlement les
ONG les mouvements anti-nucléaires
développent une communication alors
à leur fin c'est-à-dire conformément à
leur thèse qui fait resurgir la peur qui
inspire cette énergie soit par les
risques d'accident soit par la question
des déchets
alors cette inquiétude se traduit
nécessairement au plan national à la
veille d'une élection des sondages sont
faits alors sur les sondages ça vaut
pour tout sujet ils viennent ils
reviennent tantôt la popularité gagne
tantôt la popularité surgit et il en est
de même d'ailleurs pour le nucléaire
mais en toute l'année 2011 la très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens 65 à
80% déclare souhaité un arrêt progressif
sur 25 ou 30 ans des programmes
nucléaires et au bénéfice du
renouvelable
arrive à débat politique il est légitime
il faut que le Parti socialiste
choisisse son candidat sa candidate il a
pris
le pari des primaires citoyennes et donc
une élection a lieu et chacun doit
donner sa position
qu'il Aubry au nom du parti socialiste
elle-même candidate d'autres aussi dans
ce dans ce débat annonce que leur
position est de sortir du nucléaire à
l'horizon de 25 30 40 ans selon les
différentes personnalités
moi-même je
j'affirme deux convictions dans cette
primaire citoyenne qui réunira quand
même plus de 3 millions et demi de
personnes deux convictions la première
c'est que le nucléaire doit rester un
élément majeur dans notre mix
énergétique qu'il faut
affirmer que le nucléaire va rester pour
longtemps dans notre mix énergétique et
que donc nous devons assumer que je dois
assumer comme candidat une part
importante du nucléaire dans le bilan
énergétique
deuxième conviction c'est de faire
monter autant qu'il est possible les
renouvelables tout en économisant
l'énergie
c'est sur cette position là que je suis
désignée candidat le 16 octobre 2011
et
peu de temps après il y a donc un accord
électoral entre deux parties que je
respecte les Verts et le PS et qui
au-delà de ce mix à 50% que j'avais
évoqué ajoute la réduction d'un tiers de
la production installée 24 réacteurs la
fin de la filière du MOX la reconversion
des moyens de stockage des déchets
notamment
Bures et qui laisse planer une
incertitude sur l'avenir de Flamanville
je respecte toujours les parties et je
pense que si nous sommes dans une forme
de crise politique c'est parce que les
parties sont devenues évanescents et
quand des parties discutent ils sont
légitimes à le faire
c'est pas des accords de coin de table
et partis s'il y a plus de partir dans
d'autres pays il n'y aura pas de
démocratie véritable mais je suis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle les
parties ont leur responsabilités chez la
mienne j'annonce donc que je ne
respecterai pas parce que je ne suis pas
engagé l'accord qui vient d'être signé
entre le Parti socialiste et les vers
sur ce point là je reprends donc pour me
présenter devant les Français ce que
j'avais dit devant les électeurs de la
primaire socialiste l'objectif de 50% à
l'horizon 2025 je ne retiens qu'une
fermeture de centrale celle de
Fessenheim aucune autre
j'indique que je poursuivrai le chantier
de flamainville qui se substituera a
fait dans les meilleurs délais je
maintiens la filière boxe et les projets
d'enfouissement c'est à dire que je fais
en sorte que aussi bien sur cette
question du retraitement plutonium je
puisse permettre aux central de
fonctionner et les projets
d'enfouissement car il faut régler
absolument la question des déchets si on
veut faire accepter le nucléaire et ce
ces points figurent dans la page 28 du
document que vous avez tous conservé
bien sûr et que vous vous y reportez
régulièrement pour connaître l'évolution
de la situation par rapport à ma propre
pensée et bien à la page 28 du document
41e engagement vous retrouverez les
différents points que je viens
d'indiquer
vient alors le débat d'entre-deux tours
avec Nicolas Sarkozy j'ai cru comprendre
que vous aviez reçu mon prédécesseur et
qu'il a toujours cette faconde qui le
rend particulièrement attractif au moins
auprès de ces amis et j'en suis heureux
pour lui et donc je me suis replongé
dans le débat qui nous avait animé l'un
et l'autre dans ce débat donc d'avril
2012 sujet du nucléaire vient
nécessairement compte tenu de
l'importance et du caractère régalien de
choix que le Président de la République
doit faire généralement au début de son
mandat et donc Nicolas Sarkozy mais je
peux comprendre cette attitude dans un
débat utilise l'accord qui vient d'être
passé entre les vers et le Parti
socialiste sauf que je lui dis que je ne
suis pas engagé par cet accord
et que j'ai donc cette déclaration que
je refais devant lui hélas sans sa
présence mais
je pense que je peux m'adresser encore à
lui je veux garder le nucléaire comme
source principale de production
d'électricité mais réduire sa part à
mesure que les énergies renouvelables
vont monter en production et comme le
débat se prolonge je dis bon écoutez
vous voulez garder toutes les centrales
moi je
veut fermer une centrale et j'en
ouvrirai une autre Flamanville ce sera
la seule position que je prendrai sur
les centrales durant mon mandat
je veux pas anticiper sur la suite je
n'ai même pas fermé fait ce live du
roman mais je revendique cette décision
spécialement il devait fermer dès lors
que Flamanville devait ouvrir c'est sur
cette position là très claire
50%, une Centrale qui devait fermer
Flamanville qui devait se poursuivre et
le maintien de ce qui faisait la force
de notre industrie nucléaire que je me
suis présenté devant les Français et
qu'il monte accordé leur confiance alors
même que la position majoritaire de nos
concitoyens à cette époque était sans
doute très défavorable au nucléaire et
que je considérais que ma responsabilité
pas simplement de candidats de futurs
président de la République si les
Français m'accordaient leur confiance
c'était de maintenir la filière
nucléaire et de la matière à haut niveau
deuxième
interrogation que je veux poser pour
revenir sur cette année 2012 quel était
l'état de la filière nucléaire lorsque
j'arrive au responsabilités en 2012
la dernière décision de construction
d'une centrale nucléaire en France
daté de 2005 c'était Jacques Chirac
président de la République pas son
ministre d'État non c'était Jacques
Chirac président de la République qui a
décidé de lancer une nouvelle France
centrale flammonville nous sommes en
il prend une décision importante mais il
fait le choix d'un exemplaire unique
sans effet de ces risques et la grande
différence par rapport aux
grands programmes qui avaient été lancé
précédemment
le Pr donc devait être livré en 2012
et je rappelle qu'il ne l'est toujours
pas 11 ans après donc il y a
aucune décision qui a été prise durant
le mandat de Nicolas Sarkozy de lancer
des centrales
il y a que celle de Jacques Chirac qui
doit trouver son aboutissement
durant la période où moi-même j'accède à
la présidente de la République
sur Pandi puisque il y avait un projet
de lancer un deuxième réacteur à Polly
cette décision en 2011 avait été reporté
dans quête publique avait été plusieurs
fois
repoussé et
en octobre
2011 EDF et le gouvernement décide de
renvoyer à après 2012 l'enquête de Polly
deuxième situation Areva Areva était un
très grande difficulté financière
notamment à cause des retards et des
surcos de l'EPR
de Finlande c'était un chantier
important puisque c'était pour la France
l'occasion de montrer que sa filière
pouvait être non seulement fabriqué ici
dans notre pays mais exporter et là le
chantier là aussi avait été lancé en
2004 et il n'y aura pas de livraison
d'une centrale du rembour mandat en
Finlande et aujourd'hui on pense qu'au
mieux elle sera mise en service à plein
régime en 2023 ou 2024 voilà la
situation de la filière nucléaire
j'ajoute deux considérations
il y avait eu en 2009 un échec
tout à fait pénible c'était l'échec de
la vente justement d'un réacteur EPR aux
Émirats
et qui avait traduit au-delà peut-être
de savoir si on avait le meilleur
réacteur il était le meilleur mais il
était peut-être pas approprié
semble-t-il aux Émirats ce qui était
ressorti de cet échec
c'était la désorganisation de la filière
dans la présentation de l'offre
française
et qui avait mis à jour les conflits
entre EDF et Areva ce qui a d'ailleurs
donné lieu au rapport Bruce Lee qui a
fait le même constat de désorganisation
de notre filière et qui avait sans doute
été pour beaucoup dans l'échec de cette
négociation le deuxième élément c'est la
loi nomme qui est donc votée en 2010
cette loi qui vient après
des directives qui ont été prises au
niveau européen
est une loi qui va bien sûr acter les
directives les traduire les transcrire
mais qui va aller jusqu'à inventer le
mécanisme de la reine et mécanisme qui a
été pour beaucoup et je pense que les
présidents d'EDF successifs voulant
confirmer dans les difficultés que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
de cette grande entreprise nationale
et s'il y a une décision qui a été
contraire à la filière nucléaire c'est
bien la loi d'homme de 2010
je ne parle pas simplement de la
privatisation qui était d'ailleurs
antérieure je parle de ce qui s'est
produit pas simplement la mise en
concurrence mais une concurrence faussée
puisque les les concurrents de EDF
bénéficient d'un mécanisme ça a été
démontré qu'il aimait de toute façon
dans une position plus favorable que des
f donc
cette loi a prié EDF de ressources
de ressources substantielles qui lui
aurait permis d'aller encore plus loin
dans ses investissements aussi bien pour
l'énergie durable pour l'énergie
renouvelable pardon que pour l'énergie
nucléaire
voilà pourquoi il me paraît nécessaire
de il m'a paru nécessaire de redéfinir
dès mon arrivée la politique énergétique
de la France à la fois
autour d'une filière nucléaire
restructurée et de renouvelable stimulé
voilà qu'elles ont été les premières
décisions de mon mandat la première
c'est vrai monsieur le Président et je
sais que là-dessus vous n'avez pas
forcément un bon souvenir la première
décision ça a été le Conseil de
politique nucléaire du 28 septembre 2012
qui annonce la fermeture de fesadam à la
fin de mon mandat fin 2016
l'ASN l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
estimée en effet qu'il fallait 5 ans
pour
aboutir à une procédure
incontestable et permettre aussi à la
centrale de fonctionner car à la
fonctionné jusqu'à son terme elle s'est
jamais arrêtée avant d'être elle-même
fermée elle a continué à fournir de
l'électricité dans des conditions de
sécurité qui étaient totalement
préservés
alors la question avant qu'elle ne soit
posée mais pourquoi fait ce name il y
avait plusieurs raisons
si on devait fermer une centrale pour en
ouvrir une autre en l'occurrence
flammonville de plus grande dimension
d'ailleurs
la première c'était que l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire dans un avis du 3
février 2012 donc avant que je n'arrive
aux responsabilités
déclaré maître en œuvre qu'il fallait
mettre en oeuvre de très importants
travaux pour pérenniser l'exploitation
de Fessenheim le deuxième argument
c'était que c'était la plus vieille de
l'eau centrale mais c'était pas le plus
décisif
l'autre argument qui était avancé et je
sais qu'il était bien sûr par les élus
locaux contestés c'est que
la centrale était située en contrebas du
canal d'Alsace avec un risque
d'inondation et ça faisait
référence à ce qu'ils savaient ce qui
avait pu se passer même si ça n'avait
pas forcément grand rapport avec
Fukushima
je vais ajouter un dernier élément c'est
que durant le mandat de mon prédécesseur
fait cela m'avait déjà été évoqué comme
pouvant éventuellement fermer vous avez
reçu
madame cosmorisé
qui a donné un argument supplémentaire
en parlant du radier c'est-à-dire le
plancher en béton de la centrale qui
était plus fin que celui de toutes les
autres centrales et elle a héritérée
devant vous en déclarant que l'épaisseur
n'atteignait pas le niveau de sûreté de
troisième génération
mais moi ce qui me paraissait le plus
essentiel c'était que nous pouvions
faire de Fessenheim alors que nous
savions que dans 10 ans dans 15 ans nous
aurions à fermer des centrales parce
qu'elles arrivaient au terme de leur vie
il soit possible sur le site de
Fessenheim d'en faire un centre de
recherche pour précisément la
prolongation des centrales et l'hôtel
est le démantèlement
d'où cette décision est le message de
modernisation peut-être
ainsi énoncer la plus vieille de nos
centrales étaient remplacée par la plus
moderne en l'occurrence le père de
flamonville et c'est le lien qui a été
établi notamment dans la loi de
transition énergétique dont vous avez
parlé la loi de 2015 j'en dis donc
quelques mots la loi de 2015 d'abord a
été précédée par un grand débat
énergétique avec toutes les parties
prenantes patronales syndicat et du
locaux et bien sûr ONG
c'est Madame bateau qui avait été chargé
de ce débat et je pense qu'elle l'a
parfaitement menée après fait un autre
choix mais lorsque Madame Ségolène
ministre de l'écologie présente la loi
de 2015 c'est inspiré par ce que ce
débat a pu fournir la loi de 2015 c'est
la première fois que un texte du
Parlement vient fixer les objectifs
d'une politique de transition
énergétique et
crée deux instruments pour que cette
politique puisse être traduite les PPE
et la stratégie backgargo bas carbone
deuxièmement
si l'objectif de 50% à l'horizon 2025
est rappelé il n'a pas de force
obligatoire
puisque c'est un horizon qui est défini
il n'a pas de caractère normatif et
d'ailleurs il ne fait l'objet d'aucune
trajectoire
la seule disposition qui est entrée en
vigueur et qui peut avoir un caractère
contraignant nous y reviendrons c'est le
plafonnement de
63,2 gigawatts de puissance installé en
capacité de production nucléaire
aujourd'hui pour que les esprits soient
bien éclairés c'est le cas de le dire la
capacité de production et de 41
gigawatts en 2022 compte tenu des arrêts
des incidents et et des maintenances
donc le seuil de
63,2 gigawatts offrait des marges pour
ouvrir des centrales si
tes besoins dans l'avenir pour enfermer
s'il était nécessaire et il n'a jamais
été pour EDF une gêne ou une limite
dès lors que en plus EDF durant toute la
période de mon mandat a été une
entreprise qui exportait l'énergie
électrique et donc pour à peu près
dit des radiateurs ou davantage
des continuer à exporter de
l'électricité donc jamais eDF n'a été
contrainte de quelques façons à importer
de l'électricité parce qu'elle aurait
été limitée par ce plafonnement de la
production nucléaire
l'idée clairement était de maintenir le
niveau de la production nucléaire tout
en faisant monter les renouvelables et
en espérant trouver effectivement un mix
énergétique qui correspondait à mes
objectifs il s'agissait donc de
prolonger les centrales existantes en
attendant de pouvoir
éventuellement le jour venu les
renouveler la PPE donc l'instrument qui
était
créé par la loi qui avait vocation à la
traduire la programmation de l'énergie
liée explicitement elle la fermeture de
Fessenheim à l'ouverture de Flamanville
mais votez loin n'aurait pas suffi
j'avais comme obligation par les charges
qui étaient la mienne cette
responsabilité
régalienne qui est si importante en
matière du nucléaire de réorganiser la
filière qui était éclatée divisé des
organisés donc en 2014 je
prends trois grandes décisions d'abord
des décisions de nomination puisque
arrivage change de direction monsieur
Varin est appelé Framatome également à
une nouvelle
direction avec Monsieur Fontana et EDF
monsieur Levy rend pince monsieur
Proglio
une nouvelle équipe se met donc en place
mais fallait-il
clarifier la répartition des
responsabilités donc Framatome qui était
jusque là dans le périmètre d'Areva est
repris par EDF
les autres parties d'arriva sont
nationalisées car arriva était aussi
pour partie privatisée après renflement
par l'État
de 5 milliards des pertes d'Areva et le
reste donc de cette partie d'Areva qui
n'est pas transférée à EDF c'est Orano
qui est aujourd'hui chargé de du
combustible donc EDF devient le chef de
fil unique pour éviter ce qui s'était
produit notamment par rapport aux
Émirats ou ce qui était une des
explications de Flamanville
il y a EDF chef de file Framatome qui
s'occupe des chaudières et aura d'autres
du combustible c'était d'autant plus
nécessaire de réorganiser cette filière
que nous étions devant les retards
et les surcoûts qui s'accumulaient pour
Flamanville traduisant c'est vrai perte
de compétence malfaçon et aussi les
exigences de de l'autre sûreté nucléaire
qui rajoutait des contraintes qui
elle-même rajouter des coûts enfin je
pense que nous payons avec Flamanville
le défaut d'effet de série le fait qu'il
n'y ait qu'une seule centrale a été pour
beaucoup dans les charges que
Flamanville a pu supporter
enfin j'envoie une lettre de mission à
Jean-Bernard Lévy président de Dave en
2015 qui résume ce que je viens de dire
premièrement prolongation des centrales
existantes au-delà de 40 ans
c'est le plan grand carénage et nous
dégageons 50 milliards pour y parvenir
deuxième
décision préparation du programme EPR 2
pourquoi le PR2 parce que c'est un
réacteur qui est beaucoup plus adapté
justement à nos besoins beaucoup moins
lourds et qui permet sans doute
aujourd'hui de relancer la filière
troisième
décision dans cette lettre de mission de
nouvelles dépenses pour le projet SMR le
projet SMR c'est des centrales des
réacteurs beaucoup plus réduites en
volume mais sans doute beaucoup plus
facile à
réaliser et dans un délai plus court
nous maintenant les crédits d'Astrid
Astrid qui sera supprimé après mon
départ et nous faisons voter une loi CGO
pour la loi de 2016 pour permettre la
création de stock réversible en courge
en couche géologique profonde
mais j'ai eu aussi en 2016
à assurer à EDF un avenir qui était pour
partie je dis bien pour partir menacé
à la fois par des prix de l'électricité
qui était
qui était bas les prix de l'énergie et
par
nécessité d'exporter
ce qu'il ce que des pouvait être capable
de faire c'est-à-dire le réacteur EPM
donc
j'ai accepté ce qui m'était proposé par
Jean-Bernard Lévy c'est-à-dire de
soutenir la décision d'EDF de répondre
donc à inclipoint pour permettre que la
France puisse
offrir sa technologie au Royaume-Uni
puisque EDF est le seul exploitant des
centrales nucléaires au Royaume-Uni
cette décision a été controversée à
l'intérieur d'EDF à l'extérieur d'EDF
les organisations syndicales elles-mêmes
se sont posés la question moi-même j'ai
considéré qu'il fallait absolument que
hit les points puissent être réalisés
pourquoi parce que c'était ce qui nous
permettait d'avoir un plan de charge
pour les usines françaises de la filière
et de régler la question de la perte de
compétence aussi bien pour Framatome que
EDF ou pour orado et pour permettre à
EDF de réaliser cet investissement comme
pour permettre à EDF de continuer à agir
pour le renouvelable et pour le
nucléaire dans un contexte de prix bas
l'État sous ma direction à participer à
un plan de redressement de l'entreprise
l'État a renoncé à des dividendes pour
la première fois des dividendes qui lui
revenaient dans le monde de DF et à
souscrit une augmentation de capital de
4 milliards d'euros pour la première
fois depuis la création de EDF c'est à
dire depuis la Libération
l'État est venu au soutien de
l'entreprise nationale et elle est venue
on soutient de l'entreprise nationale à
cause d'une mauvaise voie celle de 2010
alors au total parce que je veux
répondre à vos questions
durant mon mandat si je dois
reconnaître ce que j'ai fait assumer et
le faire encore devant vous mes
décisions en faveur de la filière
nucléaire comme en faveur d'EDF comment
faveur des renouvelables et aussi de
tout faire pour la sobriété énergétique
je peux exprimer deux regrets
le premier regret c'est de ne pas avoir
réussi à faire monter suffisamment la
part des renouvelables
sans doute y avait-il des blocages des
recours des procédures alors que la
rentabilité de ces énergies est avérée
et que les prix sont devenus extrêmement
compétitifs
le deuxième regret c'est de ne pas avoir
pu obtenir mais comment puis-je me
mettre à la place des opérateurs et des
ingénieurs
l'ouverture de Flamanville ne serait-ce
que pour démontrer que nous avions un
réacteur capable d'être reproduit et
capable aussi de d'engager un nouveau
cycle de construction de centrale et en
plus cette ouverture était nécessaire
pour fermer Fessenheim néanmoins pendant
tout moment d'armes les 58 réacteurs ce
que j'avais donc eu si je puis dire en
héritage non pas de mes prédécesseurs en
héritage de tous les bâtisseurs de
l'industrie nucléaire les 58 réacteurs
ont fourni de l'électricité sans
difficulté majeure aucune
et avec je vous l'ai dit un seul de net
d'exportation correspondant à directeur
5 fois fait cela
il y a eu aucun relâchement dans
l'entretien et la sécurité des centrales
nous avons renouvelé le personnel d'EDF
de manière très significative durant
toute la période de mon mandat
mais en 2017 il apparaissait clairement
que la prolongation
nécessaire des centrales nucléaires sous
le contrôle de l'Autorité de sûreté et
au-delà de 50 ans ne pourrait pas les
concerner toutes et que des fermetures
étaient inévitables
ce qui
rendait encore plus nécessaire le
lancement de nouveaux réacteurs soit on
opère 2 soit en SMS
je suis également convaincu
que le nucléaire et les renouvelables
sont complémentaires et que nous avons
trop souffert
d'un débat vicié si je puis dire entre
les partisans du tout nucléaire et les
partisans du Tour renouvelable
d'ailleurs tous les scénarios de RTE qui
ont essayé de plaider pour chacune de
ces de ses causes-là non n'ont jamais
abouti à convaincre nous avons besoin et
du nucléaire et du renouvelable et que
le nucléaire est une énergie pilotable
indispensable et le renouvelable et sans
doute dans quelques années l'énergie qui
sera la moins coûteuse alors à quel
horizon peut-on avoir 50% de part de
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité j'avais pensé qu'à
l'horizon 2025 c'était possible ça ne
l'était pas
le Sénat quand nous avions discuté de la
loi de 2015 Ségolène en avait rendu
compte évoqué 2030 et c'était une
majorité de droite ensuite il a été dit
2035 j'ai compris qu'Elisabeth borde
parlait maintenant de 2050 mais ce qui
fait que finalement tout le monde
convient qu'il faut une part
substantielle de nucléaire et une part
de renouvelable avec une sobriété
énergétique d'autant que c'était ça le
calcul qui pouvait être fait même si
durement modal est prévisions que de 2D
RTE était une stagnation de la
production d'électricité alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
conscients et je vais pas ici en donner
les explications chacun sait qu'il y
aura plus de consommation d'électricité
donc la part du nucléaire forcément
baissera même si nous construisons et il
faut construire des nouveaux des
nouvelles centrales à la place de celle
qui devrait si elles sont dans une
impossibilité d'être poursuivie par
rapport à ce que nous dira la SN arrêtez
ce que je crois aussi c'est que des
objectifs peuvent être fixés c'est bien
qu'ils le soi mais il se passe toujours
des événements qui un moment bouleverse
les prévisions les mieux établies et là
en ce moment nous vivons cette situation
et d'ailleurs sans que personne ne les
souhaitait on va avoir une part de la du
nucléaire de la production d'électricité
qui va être peut-être de l'ordre de 60%
si si les incidences se prolongent alors
même que ça ne fait pas partie de ce qui
était une volonté du Président de la
République ou de tel ou telle composante
de la vie politique non c'est parce que
c'est une réalité qui se qui se pose à
nous et que nous devons absolument
dépasser ce qui va compter c'est
l'excellence des deux filières
nucléaires comme renouvelables et une
répartition optimale des investissements
enfin la sobriété énergétique celle dont
on parle mais que l'on ne voit pas
il y a pas de centrale de sobriété
énergétique par définition il y a des
comportements
et bien c'est le grand enjeu et c'est
pour ça que l'isolation thermique est
sans doute l'investissement le plus
rentable pour que nous ayons moins à
consommer d'électricité et d'énergie
faut-il encore que nous puissions donner
un volume budgétaire à cette priorité
voilà pourquoi je termine là si votre
commission d'enquête
au-delà de la responsabilité qu'il faut
établir à chaque époque de ceux qui ont
gouverné pris des décisions exécutées
même au-delà des responsabilités votre
commission
doit aboutir à des conclusions le plus
conscien possible si l'on veut justement
faire
œuvre utile et assurer une forme de
continuité ça n'empêchera pas les débats
entre ceux qui sont toujours réservés
sur l'industrie nucléaire ou qui
colporte quelquefois des doutes sur
cette industrie ça m'épuisera pas le
débat sur ce qui contestent les énergies
renouvelables en considérant qu'elle
défigures le paysage ou empêche d'usage
de la mère comme il convient mais si
nous voulons dépasser ces
réticences ces oppositions et ces
fractures nous avons intérêt à trouver
des domaines de consensus et finalement
celui-là compte tenu de ce que je viens
de dire de la transition énergétique de
ce qui se passe par rapport à un conflit
qui forcément nous interroge sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique nous
sommes dans le contexte où il est
possible d'arriver à se consensus
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour ce propos introductif déjà très
complet qui balaye bon nombre de
questions j'imagine que les membres de
la commission d'enquête
avait imaginé et préparé j'aurais
néanmoins quelques questions à vous
poser une simple précision comme vous
l'avez dit vous-même dans votre propos
introductif le moment du débat est
particulier il semblerait que on n'est
pas besoin d'aller voter trop vite bon
attendre le début de la séance je ne
suspendrais qu'en cas de vote voilà je
le dis aux membres de la commission s'il
n'y a pas de vote je ne suspends pas
empêcher le débat et créer un incident
peut-être non regrettable qui qui
pourraient aboutir ou au rejet d'un
texte ou à son approbation sans la
volonté de des membres de la commission
d'enquête alors là il pourrait y avoir
une commission d'enquête sur ma propre
responsabilité et je ne serai pas
comment répondre j'ai bien compris non
mais je s'il n'y a pas de vote il n'y a
pas de raison de suspendre puisque c'est
bien le vote qui emporte la décision
dans l'hémicycle le débat n'est que
l'élément préparatoire du vote et qu'il
a déjà eu largement lieu monsieur le
Président je me permets une première
question j'en ai bien que député de
Fessenheim j'en ai posé très peu dans
cette commission d'enquête pour que
justement nos travaux ne soient pas
focalisés sur ce qui a été très
largement un symbole plus que
pourrait considérer un symptôme aussi
mais enfin plus un symbole que une
décision structurelle en tant que telle
et je vais vous poser une question qui
fait lien avec l'objet de notre
commission d'enquête qui est plus le
processus décisionnel et la façon dont
les stratégies imaginez au niveau
président de la République et je vous
remercie d'avoir confirmé tout cela
se conjugue avec la mise en oeuvre qui
elle relève des opérateurs quels qu'ils
soient administratifs privés par a privé
par un public
vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
introductif vous avez très vite en 2012
annoncé votre volonté de fermer les deux
réacteurs de Fessenheim à l'horizon 2016
c'est une décision qui ne sera pas mise
en oeuvre dans le dialogue entre
votre niveau de responsabilité de chef
d'État le niveau ministériel et
l'entreprise kedf où est-ce que vous
identifiez les freins à la mise en
oeuvre de de cette décision est-ce que
vous avez cherché à lutter contre
j'avais jamais pensé que fermé une
centrale pouvait
se faire
dès lors que le Président de la
République avait parlé parce qu'il
s'agit d'abord de puissance installées
il s'agit d'un outil qui mérite respect
et de personnel qui attendent de savoir
quel sort va leur être réservé et d'élu
locaux qui sont inquiets de savoir ce
que l'État est capable de proposer comme
solution alternative par ailleurs EDF
avait des intérêts qu'elle demandait à
défendre
il se trouve que il y avait un processus
aussi d'indemnisation qui devait être
prévues qui d'ailleurs a été réglé à la
fin
et il y avait tout un ensemble de
procédures
qui devait être également réglée et avec
la vie de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
donc pour pour ce qui me concerne je
m'étais engagé devant les Français pour
que nous ne fermions qu'une seule
centrale que nous accueillons
Flamanville même s'il y avait des doutes
déjà sur Flamanville des réserves des
des critiques sur le coup et c'est vrai
que le coût a été multiplié par 5 et que
le délai a été allongé jusqu'en 2025
sans doute mais c'était mon choix de
faire que nous puissions ouvrir
Flamanville parce que si nous avions
fermé Flamanville en 2012
et bien c'était la fin de la filière EPR
comment aurait-il été possible
d'exporter de le père en Chine au
Royaume-Uni on l'avait déjà fait en
Finlande si nous-même nous renoncions à
Flamanville donc pour moi l'essentiel
c'était d'ouvrir flamant ville c'est ça
que j'ai dit je vais le regret que ce ne
soit pas fait même si ce regret mon
successeur peut l'avoir aussi et mon
prédécesseur également donc mais pour ce
qui concerne fait cela et bien voilà
c'était lié à Flamanville d'une part et
deuxièmement EDF nous fixer des des
règles des procédures et je me suis pas
non plus
gendarmé tous les jours pour dire à quel
moment il faut fermer Fessenheim ils ont
souhaité par par strict respect de ma
parole que ce soit fait à la fin de de
mon mandat c'est que la Royal a eu
l'obligeant de faire un décret dont on
sait qu'il n'avait pas de de valeur
juridique qu'il a fallu donc attendre
quelques années pour que ça puisse se
faire et d'ailleurs sans que Flamanville
soit ouvert
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
dans votre propos introductif vous avez
également émis quelques critiques sur la
loi dite nomme
nouvelle organisation du marché de
l'électricité
nous avons entendu votre Ministre de
l'Énergie avant enfin certains de vos
ministres de l'énergie avant vous
puisque on a eu qu'il y en a eu quatre
et nous en avait entendu au moins deux
d'entre eux
on lui a posé la question de de la loi
non de la reine de l'évolution possible
du tarif de la reine qui était présente
dans la loi Nome elle a été surprise de
la question et semblait découvrir cette
possibilité
qu'en est-il à votre niveau est-ce que
cette préoccupation des règles de la loi
nomme était présente au cours de votre
mandat et si oui avez-vous envisagé de
les modifier puisque a priori vous ne
les avez pas modifié bien sûr que
Jean-Bernard Lévy ça a été une de ses
premières démarches
est venue me voir pour me dire que
la reine donc ce mécanisme qui oblige DF
à fournir
sans Terra wattheure à des concurrents
qui ensuite revendent à des prix plus
élevés étaient une une concurrence
faussée et qui ne crée aucune capacité
physique supplémentaire pénaliser EDF et
entraîner une spéculation bon donc nous
avons envisagé Jean-Bernard Lévy et
moi-même
et avec le gouvernement donc de mener
une négociation avec la Commission
européenne pour relever
de quelques euros le prix de session
nous pensions pouvoir arriver à 52 euros
et c'était dans l'année 2015 il s'est
trouvé que dans l'année 2015 les prix de
l'énergie ont été tellement faibles de
l'électricité pardon ont été tellement
faibles que cette négociation avait même
plus de sens puisque le mécanisme de la
reine que vous connaissez bien il est
intéressant pour les concurrents quand
le prix est de marcher de gros et
au-dessus des 42 si l'on réussit de 52
euros mais quand le prix tombe à 30
euros ce qui était le cas bah le
mécanisme de la reine à ce moment-là ne
joue plus et les concurrents ne vont pas
se fournir EDF mais bon sur le sur le
marché donc à ce moment là bon nous
étions tout près d'avoir peut-être la
Morse d'une position favorable mais
cette possibilité est tombée et je le
regrette profondément
mais du coup l'inversion du
marché oui de rapport de prix sur le
marché ne vous a pas plus inquiété que
cela quand au dispositif
dans mon mandat de prix de de marché
inférieur supérieur à 42 euros et il se
trouve c'était d'ailleurs pas forcément
très franchement une contrainte on avait
un prix de l'énergie durant mon mandat
lié d'ailleurs à la récession qui
s'était produite faible croissance qui
expliquait d'ailleurs les les
projections de RTE en termes de de
consommation d'électricité on avait donc
des prix de l'énergie qui était plutôt
bas et un prix de l'électricité plutôt
bas et c'est vrai que ce mécanisme est
particulièrement pervers quand le
prix s'élève et c'est ce qui s'est
notamment produit pendant la crise que
nous venons de traverser
je vous pose encore une question avant
de faire circuler la parole et puis on
aurait d'autres en fonction du temps qui
nous restera
la question du nucléaire est une avant
tout une question de filière en France
durant votre mandat un gros doute s'est
posé sur la viabilité d'Alstom et vous
avez donc eu à traiter la transaction le
rachat d'Alstom par General Electrics
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de mots
de ce dossier qui revient dans
l'actualité avec une tentative de retour
au capitaux français de cette de cette
entreprise
oui elle somme n'était pas une
entreprise publique au temps où j'étais
président c'était une entreprise privée
principale actionnaire était Bouygues et
ces dirigeants envisagés de céder donc
par de leur activité notamment l'énergie
leur préférence aller vers général
électrique et les négociations étaient
déjà largement engagées quand le
ministre Montebourg a été informé qu'il
y avait ces transactions et que j'ai été
amené à provoquer l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour que nous trouvions la
meilleure solution pour pour général
électrique pour les salariés concernés
et aussi pour notre propre filière
nucléaire
nous avions en fait deux options sur la
table l'option général électrique et
l'option Siemens
et Général Electric bon on lui posait
des conditions et d'ailleurs elles ont
été
mises sur le papier même si pour
certaines
générales électriques essayer de s'en
soustraire il y avait des pénalités qui
ont été versées par rapport aux emplois
donc il y avait général evil qui était
donc déjà basé sur le sol français
notamment à Belfort et qui avait une
histoire dans dans le nucléaire français
et il y avait ce qui est mince
problème de CM1 c'est que l'Allemagne
venait de décider la sortie du nucléaire
c'était compliqué de prendre un
opérateur
Siemens qui qui serait devenu
majoritaire
un opérateur qui ne fait pas de
nucléaire dans son pays mais qui en
ferait chez nous deuxièmement Siemens
voulait prendre toute l'activité
d'Alstom c'est à dire l'activité
transport et l'activité énergie donc
nous avons j'ai considéré que il fallait
aller vers général électrique en posant
des conditions et même si nous avons de
très bon rapport avec ses minces et que
nos amis allemands ont été très heureux
de pouvoir avoir cette coopération avec
tout c'était difficile dès lors que
l'Allemagne était sorti du nucléaire
très bien merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président je vous
remercie monsieur le Président de la
République pour votre propos liminaire
très très précis et éclairant et pour
les premières réponses à vos questions
une première question et j'allais dire
la seule sur le fameux accord 2015 qui
était largement discuté ici d'abord vous
avez d'abord largement répondu question
et donc je veux pas être excessivement
long mais je voudrais simplement si vous
le permettez mieux comprendre
ce que selon vous impliquait cette
accord en termes de enfin pardon de
l'accord transcrit dans la loi de 2015
excusez-moi dans la loi de 2015 de
50%, ce que ce qu'il impliquait en
termes de nombre de réacteurs c'est à
dire que et on a eu cette discussion
avec de nombreuses auditionnés à cette
époque les prévisions de consommation
enfin de demandes d'électricité était à
peu près stable dans le temps et donc la
réduction de la part du nucléaire
incluait mécaniquement la fermeture d'un
certain nombre de réacteurs et la
question que je voulais vous poser de
manière préliminaire c'est l'ordre de
grandeur de réacteurs à fermer à cet
horizon 2025 quel était-il et est-ce que
de 2012 à 2015 vous avez eu j'imagine
que c'est le cas des échanges avec le
l'opérateur de réseau notamment RTE sur
la pratique habilité de ce nombre de
réacteurs que j'imagine vous allez nous
préciser
j'avais pris des engagements de ne
fermer aucun réacteur autre que fait ses
durant mon mandat donc la question
pouvait se poser après
c'est-à-dire à l'horizon 2025 ou si
président qui me succédait
si moi-même j'avais souhaité être de
nouveau candidats
et à faire
alors donc la loi de 2015
ne fixe aucune trajectoire et ne parle
aucun autre réacteur que celui de
Fessenheim par rapport à Flamanville
qu'on trouve dans la PPE
les 24 réacteurs de ce fameux accord
psvert c'est quoi je me suis aussi posé
cette question
en fait les 24 réacteurs qui avaient été
évoqué dans un dans une négociation à
laquelle je n'étais pas parti prenante
puisque j'étais déjà candidat c'était
les 24 réacteurs les plus vieux
ceux qui devaient à l'horizon 2025 2030
2035 un moment être éventuellement
remplacé sauf que les choix que je fais
en 2015 c'est pas de fixer la limite à
40 ans comme c'était prévu initialement
dans la durée de vie des centrales
puisque l'ensemble le plan carénage
grand carénage on est déjà à 50 ans
maintenant on évoque 60 ans peut-être
davantage même si toutes les centrales
ne pourront pas être portées jusqu'à
cette limite d'âge donc pour ce qui me
concernait je considérais
qu'effectivement
nous aurions à fermer des des réacteurs
dans un délai qui était peut-être bien
au-delà de 2025 mais je n'avais aucune
aucun élément qui me donnait à penser
que ça se ferait
un rythme élevé et que ça pouvait même
être repoussé pouce qui concerne les
projections de RTE parce que ça c'était
très intéressant à l'époque
monsieur Proglio qui était président
d'EDF lui je dois le reconnaître qui
acceptait l'idée des 50% même si il a pu
dire le contraire devant votre
commission mais il était candidat à sa
propre succession donc ça quelquefois ça
ça autorise quelques souplesse mais lui
ce qu'il nous disait à la différence de
RTU il lui disait mais si c'est vrai si
la consommation électrique
monte nous serons à un moment ou un
autre alors ce que sera 2025 2027 2030
mais nous serons à 50%
et alors que RTE sur des projections de
stagnation de la consommation électrique
et en fait je dois reconnaître celui qui
avait raison pas en 2015 car là on était
dans une période économique qui était
pas qui était pas formidable et on
n'avait pas cette pression aussi liée à
la lutte contre le réchauffement et la
neutralité carbone et on n'avait pas non
plus
cette
obligation de supprimer du gaz puisque
nous n'en faisons que peut venir de
l'extérieur et bien nous pouvions penser
que que
il y avait d'un côté ceux qui pensaient
que il y avait une progression de de la
consommation d'électrique et d'autres
qui ne le pensaient pas
je remercie monsieur le Président une
dernière question peut-être sur le
dernière question mais je l'ai pose
ensemble sur la filière nucléaire avant
de passer la suite une question
rapidement pour être sûr si vous
permettez le président d'avoir compris
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
pandi le fait que le sous le précédent
quinquennat la décision l'idée de faire
une enquête publique avait été renvoyée
poste 2012 pour être sûr que si j'ai
bien compris implicitement ce que vous
dites c'est que vous décidez ainsi que
votre gouvernement de ne pas mener cette
enquête publique et la deuxième question
qui est plus pour comprendre alors on
n'a pas évidemment le contenu de tout ce
qui se passe dans un Conseil de
politique nucléaire mais vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il y avait à la fois
l'idée de réduire la part du nucléaire
et dans le même temps de renforcer la
filière à l'export et d'ailleurs il y a
un des conseils de politique nucléaire
celui de janvier 2013 où il y a des
annonces sur les compétences et les
métiers à l'export et je reviens
volontairement sur ce point parce que de
nombreux acteurs ou de la filière ou des
responsables politiques nous ont parlé
d'un de l'effet signal qui aurait
emporté qu'il aurait emporté sur tout le
reste de la loi de 2015
sur la filière dans le même temps on
constate que vous prenez des mesures en
tout cas qu'il y a des annonces sur la
compétence donc quel est votre avis sur
sur l'effet de façon l'impact de cet
effet signal d'après un certain nombre
de responsables sur la filière alors que
vous semblez vouloir pousser la filière
à l'export
alors d'abord un mot surlis
donc Nicolas Sarkozy Président de la
République
annonce
un deuxième réacteur européen en janvier
en mai 2010 il y a des réunions
publiques je pense que Monsieur jumelles
pourra vous en parler parce qu'il en a
eu un certain nombre de manifestations
et en mai 2011 c'est-à-dire quelques
semaines après
la catastrophe de Fukushima le doute
s'installe et Monsieur de Marjorie à
l'époque président de Total parce que
bien comprendre que panli c'est pas EDF
seulement c'est EDF GDL GDF et total ce
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs forcément la
bonne approche mais monsieur de Marjorie
annonce que une réflexion a été arrêtée
pour parler
on est en mai 2011 et c'est vrai que
l'enquête publique qui devait débat
débuter en juin 2011 elle est reportée à
octobre 2011
et même si Monsieur Sarkozy faisait des
meetings dans toutes les centrales
nucléaires où il pouvait se déplacer il
se trouve que en octobre 2011 il reporte
le l'enquête publique et EDF annonce à
la fin de l'année 2011 que l'enquête est
reporté à une date indéterminée
sous-entendu je peux comprendre
d'ailleurs EDF disant puisque aucune
décision n'a été prise
de lancer l'enquête publique par le
président sortant qui peut être demain
le nous le nouveau président attendons
qu'il y ait vote des Français pour
savoir ce qu'il y a lieu de faire bon
donc j'avais annoncé moi-même que oui à
Flamanville mais c'était la seule
centrale qui devait ouvrir bien sûr que
PANI mais ne fait pas forcément avoir
une enquête publique mais je n'arrête
pas le projet de Pandi définitivement on
continue de garder cette idée et
heureusement d'ailleurs qu'on ne l'a pas
réalisé le projet de Polly à ce moment
là parce qu'on l'aurait réalisé sans
doute avec le père tel que nous le
construisons avec difficulté à
Flamanville alors que demain par les
décisions qui viennent d'être annoncées
ça va être le PR2 qui sera à Flamanville
et qui va bénéficier lui d'un effet de
série
c'est ça qui va lui permettre à mon avis
de pouvoir être réalisé je l'espère plus
plus rapidement voilà pour panie alors
ensuite sur le fait que il n'y avait pas
eu de lancement de programme nucléaire
durant toute la période je veux dire
post Jacques Chirac Flamanville
qu'il y en aurait pas autre Flamanville
qui devait ouvrir durant mon propre
mandat qui avait un risque pour la
filière de perte de compétences donc il
fallait absolument assurer une
exportation nous avions quand même le
souci de ne pas donner l'image à avec ce
qui se produisait en Finlande d'un
projet qui qui sans lisait même si
finalement il va finir par ressortir
mais bon à quel prix pour pour Areva la
perte d'Areva c'est quand même l'État
sous ma direction qui l'a compensé mais
donc il était très important que nous
puissions exporter c'est pour ça que je
soutiens ink les potes parce que ça fait
partie de ce que nous devions faire pour
la filière et donc cette nécessité
d'exportation je l'ai d'autant plus
porté que nous avons essayé de négocier
en Inde et ailleurs des projets
d'exportation de l'EPR et que nous
avions de ce point de vue un atout c'est
que la Chine avait été capable sans
doute avec des des exigences de sécurité
qui n'ont pas forcément grand chose à
voir avec ce que nous demande l'Autorité
de sûreté du clair ici en France mais il
y avait quand même des EPS qui
fonctionnaient donc il était très
important que au maintienne cette
stratégie d'exportation pour entretenir
les compétences faire travailler les
usines et donner ce qui n'était pas le
cas un semblant d'effet de série pour le
père
je vous remercie je reviens à des
questions sur les énergies renouvelables
et puis leur développement et le
conséquences les conséquences de leur
développement au sens large dans les
précédentes auditions de très nombreuses
personnalités y compris des ministres
qui ont eu l'honneur de servir le
gouvernement que vous aviez nommé
nous ont fait part des alertes qui ont
été remontés ou des administrations ou
des responsables de réseau ou même au
sein du gouvernement avec des
discussions si on a bien compris
certaines auditions ministérielles
vivent et c'est normal c'est la
dynamique interministérielle sur la
faisabilité pour le réseau c'est à dire
la capacité d'avoir une montée en charge
à hauteur de 50% c'est ni une question
de point de pourcentage ni d'horizon
c'est à dire la capacité à assurer la
pilotabilité de la production et son son
équilibre offre demande dans un nouveau
monde celui où les énergies
renouvelables prenaient cette place
importante quel a été la teneur des
discussions et est-ce que vous avez eu
l'impression que du point de vue du
réseau les décisions qui étaient prises
sous votre mandat aurait mérité d'être
complété ou avait besoin d'être complété
par des investissements dans le réseau
ou de nouvelles mesures en plus de
celles qui ont été prises dans la boîte
oui j'ai dit mon regret que nous n'ayons
pas pu monter plus de redoublables pas
simplement pour atteindre l'objectif
à l'horizon 2025 2030 ou au-delà mais
tout simplement parce que nous avons
besoin d'une filière du renouvelable
mais je dois reconnaître que EDF sous
mon instruction à engagé des
financements importants pour le réseau
et pas simplement pour le renouvelable
et a fait en sorte que EDF puisse être
une entreprise qui puisse être
exemplaire exemplaire pour le réseau
c'est-à-dire au service de toutes les
énergies renoies pas forcément celles
qui produisait et exemplaire dans sa
capacité à développer du renouvelable je
pense que les les complications ne sont
pas venues seulement du réseau même si
c'est un élément de de compréhension son
lieu de de retard de blocage et c'est si
le gouvernement actuel a voulu qu'il y
ait une loi pour pour faciliter
j'imagine que ça doit correspondre à cet
état des lieux
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
et une dernière question puisque vous
avez devancé ma question sur le les
énergies renouvelables et la difficulté
que les gouvernements successifs ont eu
à les développer et atteindre
les objectifs
qui portent finalement sur ce que vous
avez mentionné de la divertissification
en 2013 l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
rend un avis dans lequel elle souligne
le risque potentiel qui pèse sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement du pays en
cas de défaut générique comme on dit du
parc et c'est ce qui se produit et c'est
ce qui intéresse aussi beaucoup notre
commission dans le processus décisionnel
c'est de comprendre quelles peuvent être
les relations entre un président de la
République et l'entreprise quai EDF qui
gère un parc non pas standardisé
puisqu'il y avait au moins deux types de
réacteurs mais tout de même est-ce que
c'est une question qui a émergé la
possibilité une fois notamment la vie
rendue qui a émergé d'ailleurs on le
constate aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
c'est une question qui a émergé est-ce
que c'est des alertes qui ont été
retransmises par vous votre gouvernement
et quel quels étaient la nature des
qualités à la nature des discussions sur
ce point avec l'opérateur et votre
gouvernement
le défaut générique
on le voit c'est la menace principale
c'est à dire on peut avoir des positions
plus ou moins
volontariste sur le nucléaire et ou plus
ou moins
sentimental ou
[Musique]
encourageante par rapport au nucléaire
et j'ai dit combien il était important
de maintenir une filière nucléaire de de
haute qualité
et dans un contexte de sécurité renforcé
mais il peut se produire un défaut et
c'est ce qui arrive en ce moment
et à défaut même
cumulatif c'est à dire où on voit que
cette au même moment que sont révélés
l'affaire de la corrosion sous
contrainte
mais aussi les fissures mais aussi des
si j'ai bien compris des tuyauteries qui
ont été mal réparés un moment où et qui
remonte à très loin donc le risque à un
moment où nos centrales ne puissent pas
produire heureusement
fait quand même notre notre fiabilité
c'est que les centrales n'ont pas le
même âge n'ont pas les mêmes structures
n'ont pas les mêmes fabrication
et donc ne peuvent pas d'un seul coup
être paralysé alors parler de l'Autorité
de sûreté
bien sûr que ça fait partie de son
devoir de nous dire attention qu'est-ce
que vous avez préparé dans cette
hypothèse là bon là-dessus j'ai demandé
aussi bien au président
pro-glio que président les vides de me
rassurer de me dire qu'est-ce que vous
faites et c'est pour ça que c'était très
important que votre commission d'enquête
puisse établir les investissements
d'entretien de maintenance ont été
toujours à un niveau très élevé à EDF il
y a eu aucune économie qui a été faite
sur ce domaine là ça aurait été possible
compte tenu de ce qu'avait EDF à
financer le renouvelable flamant vide
qui lui coûtait d'autres opérations à
l'extérieur et bien EDF est ça j'ai
veillé à tout moment sur ce qui était
l'essentiel pour nous c'était la
permanence de ce réseau la capacité de
pouvoir fournir de l'électricité au
meilleur prix ce qui a été largement le
cas et avec
le volume de production qui sauvent en
2016 pour être tout à fait honnête où
nous avions connu une petite alerte et
où nous avons au lieu de faire 400
terawatts 380 mais il y avait eu déjà
cette petite là mais c'était pas le
défaut systémique mais bien sûr que ça
fait partie à mon avis du rôle du
président de la République au-delà de
ses choix de veiller pour la sécurité
puisque c'est votre sujet la sécurité la
souveraineté la dépend que la sécurité
puisse être garantie au consommateurs
merci à Monsieur maisonnet
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la République François
Hollande merci pour vos propos
liminaires et pour vos premières
réponses je voudrais tout d'abord
revenir sur le fameux seuil des 50% et
votre volonté de développer
considérablement les énergies
renouvelables avec des projets ambitieux
alors quand je dis ambitieux c'est pas
forcément de façon positive en la
matière puisque vous souhaitiez passer
la barre des 50% d'énergie renouvelable
autrement dit réduire la part du
nucléaire à moins de 50% dans notre
production d'électricité et quand on
parle d'énergie renouvelable on parle
évidemment pour l'essentiel de l'éolien
et du photovoltaïque aussi en sachant
que le nucléaire n'est pas aisément
modulable dans les périodes hivernales
s'en vont ni soleil quelles énergies
autre que des énergies polluantes telles
que le gaz ou le charbon comptiez vous
utilisez
deuxième question je veux revenir sur la
perte de nombreux fleurons industriels
sous votre mandat
Alstom techniques techniques pardon
Lafarge Alcatel
Arnaud Montebourg on a d'ailleurs
égrainé la longue liste lors de son
audition ces entreprises sont pourtant
des acteurs clés pour notre souveraineté
y compris énergétique de nombreux
observateurs ont pointé la faiblesse de
la France en matière d'intelligence
économique à tort ou à raison vous nous
le direz notamment dans durant la
période de votre quinquennat
qu'avez-vous fait pour protéger ces
groupes stratégiques sur le cas d'Alstom
notamment nous avons nous pas fait
preuve d'une naïve découpable en
laissant les Américains tendre en piège
à un groupe essentiel pour notre
souveraineté peut-on selon vous parler
ici d'un acte de guerre économique
sur l'industrie du photovoltaïque et de
l'éolien malgré des investissements qui
se chiffre en milliards d'euros nous
n'avons pas assisté à l'émergence d'une
industrie nationale des renouvelables au
contraire sous votre mandat la grande
majorité de l'argent que nous avons
investi à contribuer à renforcer des
industries étrangères aujourd'hui la
majeure partie des éoliennes panneaux
solaires français viennent au mieux
d'Allemagne et au pire de la Chine
comment l'expliquez-vous
sur l'éolien encore avez-vous pris
conscience des conséquences négatives
Corée leur implantation massive sur les
territoires prenons l'exemple d'un
département comme la somme qui est un
département relativement pauvre ou près
de 1000 éoliennes ont déjà été implantés
des milliers de logements perdus
beaucoup de valeur où sont même
désormais invendables des territoires
ont perdu le peu d'attractivité qu'ils
avaient les habitants devant le fait
accompli sont souvent désespérés
aviez-vous conscience de ces
externalités négatives c'est le
président
au niveau européen quelle a été votre
position vis-à-vis de Bruxelles qui
reprochait à la France d'être en retard
en matière de renouvelable alors que
nous étions l'un des pays faut le dire
les plus vertueux du monde en matière
d'électricité décarbonée grâce au
nucléaire avez-vous tenté de changer les
règles de l'Union européenne afin que le
nucléaire soit vu comme ce qu'il est
c'est à dire une énergie décarbonée
aussi qu'elle a été votre position
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne lorsque ces
derniers ont décidé de fermer leur parc
nucléaire les aviez-vous mis en garde
contre la dépendance au très polluant
charbon ainsi qu'aux gaz russe
aviez-vous pris la mesure de la menace
que représentée la dépendance au gaz
russe de nos voisins les prix de
l'électricité français étant liés
étroitement lié au prix allemand
enfin la transition énergétique implique
une augmentation faramineuse de nos
besoins en terre rare nécessaire pour
construire les voitures électriques
panneaux solaires éoliennes smartphone
etc c'était rare sont à 90% produites en
Chine extraites et produite en Chine
cette problématique est soulevée depuis
peu de temps mais je souhaiterais savoir
si lors de votre quinquennat vous aviez
déjà des informations sur ce problème et
si vous aviez commencé à réfléchir sur
cet enjeu je vous remercie monsieur le
président
bien beaucoup de questions dans votre
intervention
je vais aller à l'essentiel il ne
s'agissait pas pour nous en faisant
monter les renouvelables de diminuer
notre capacité de production nucléaire
j'ai été suffisamment clair
il y a eu le
plafonnement au niveau et nous n'avons
fermé aucune centrale durant tout moment
d'un donc il s'agissait pas de réduire
de la capacité de production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire pour
faire du renouvelable il s'agissait de
favoriser du renouvelable en plus du
nucléaire et pour les raisons que vous
avez indiquées parce que le nucléaire
est une une énergie pilotable et que les
renouvelables devaient se développer
pour arriver à des niveaux de de
compétitivité qui leur permettait de de
ne pas être soutenus financièrement car
nous soutenions financièrement les
énerves la montée des énergies
renouvelables vous savez qu'il y avait
une contribution qui était faite pour
que précisément lorsque nous payons
notre électricité une
pas des centrales nucléaires nous avons
fermé des centrales au fioul et au
charbon
vous avez compris que je ne suis plus
président de la République même si vous
devez le regretter au fond de vous même
mais je ne le suis plus donc
nous nous avons fermé des centrales qui
utilisaient de l'énergie fossile parce
que ayant signé l'accord de la Coop 21
j'étais bien amené
à fermer des centrales et c'est là aussi
pour les salariés concernés qui soient
dans le nucléaire qui soit dans le
charbon ou qui soit dans ou qui soit
dans le fioul ben c'était pas si évident
et nous l'avons fait de l'avons fait
pour les raisons qui tiennent à nos
engagements climatiques deuxièmement
vous m'avez interrogé sur Bruxelles
prend des directives on a vu qu'elle
pouvait avoir des conséquences la loi de
l'homme si on ne savait pas irrésister à
un moment mais Bruxelles n'a jamais été
particulièrement favorable au nucléaire
parce que majoritairement très
majoritairement les pays européens ne
sont pas dans l'énergie nucléaire
mais nous nous avons toujours tenu bon
et avec quelques pays les pays qui sont
dans dans
le nucléaire c'est la République tchèque
c'est Slovaquie
il a pas beaucoup mais nous avons tenu
bon en faisant en sorte que les autres
ne soient pas dans la condamnation il
l'était souvent nous avons tenu bon et
rien nous a été demandé je n'ai jamais
reçu bien comment
s'imaginable je n'avais jamais reçu une
décision venant de Bruxelles une
recommandation une injonction me disant
vous avez vraiment trop de nucléaire en
France débarrassez-vous de cette énergie
pas plus que je n'ai dit à Madame Merkel
qui avait pris sa décision avant que je
n'arrivais au pouvoir je t’intime
l'ordre au nom des rapports
franco-allemands de de rallumer tes
centrales nucléaires non ça ça fait
partie dans le dans le cadre européen
chacun poursuit la politique énergétique
de son choix à la condition
qu'elle corresponde aux objets aux
objectifs globaux de neutralité carbone
et de réduction des énergies fossiles
donc je n'ai rien reçu de ce point de
vue là et par rapport au gaz russe vous
avez raison d'assister là-dessus moi
j'ai alerté plusieurs fois
mes collègues européens sur la
dépendance à l'égard du gaz russe et
notamment de ce grand projet qui est
intéressé aussi des entreprises
françaises qui s'appelaient
gazoduc Nord Stream 2 et dont on l'a vu
que ça avait été un élément qui qui
avait été utilisé par Vladimir Poutine y
compris après l'invasion de l'Ukraine et
j'avais mis en garde
notamment en gala Merkel qui elle
pensait que c'était un facteur de
facilité pour convaincre Vladimir
Poutine de rester raisonnable non
c'était d'un élément dépendances et de
ce point de vue et je pense que votre
commission pourra l'établir nous avons
réduit notre approvisionnement en gaz
venant de de Russie ce qui fait que
lorsque les Russes ou quand nous même
par processus des sanctions nous avons
dit nous ne voulons pas de gazeus ou les
Russes nous ont pas envoyé de gaz russe
nous n'avons pas été particulièrement
bouleversés comme l'ont été les
Allemands d'où nous sommes de ce point
de vue là sur la sécurité nous sommes
débarrassés de de cette dépendance ça ne
veut pas dire que nous ne sommes pas
dépendants d'autres pays
on les connaît et
sur également ce que vous avez dit et
qui est juste sur le fait que les ça
relève de ce qu'on appelle
l'indépendance on peut se dire le
nucléaire nous sommes totalement
indépendants parce que nous produisons
de l'électricité avec
avec
de l'uranium sauf que l'uranium ne vient
pas de nulle part
nous sommes conscients moi je ne
participe pas de du fantasme sur lequel
il pourrait y avoir un risque de ne pas
être approvisionné en uranium mais nous
sommes dépendants du Kazakhstan du Niger
d'un syndrome de pays donc voilà nous
sommes jamais complètement libres et
souverain ce qui est vrai sur les
panneaux aussi
ou sur les terrains
nous n'avons pas pu c'est pas l'état qui
peut le faire à la place des entreprises
compte tenu des prix qui sont fournis
par les Chinois peut-être qu'il y
aura-t-il des éléments qui un moment
sanctionneront éventuellement des
dumpings mais pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas pu développer cette
industrie de de fabrication de panneaux
même s'il y en a quelques-unes mais
j'avoue qui ne sont pas au niveau de la
compétition
sur ce que vous avez dit sur je peux le
comprendre parce que dans tout
département chaque fois qu'on installe
des champs panneaux solaires des
éoliennes il y a toujours des
contestations mais faut bien comprendre
que si
et pour les populations c'est c'est le
sentiment que c'est toujours dans les
mêmes régions que l'on va pour mettre ce
type d'installation mais si on ne va pas
vers nos objectifs de développement du
renouvelable
et avec les difficultés qu'on a pour
l'instant pour avoir une pleine capacité
nucléaire pour quelques années
comment fera-t-on c'est là qu'on sera
peut-être amené à aller chercher ce que
des énergies qu'on ne veut pas utiliser
donc il faut aller dans un respect des
populations mais il faut aller vers les
énergies renouvelables ce que c'est un
élément aussi souvent T et si on le fait
pas on peut se retrouver dans une
situation de j'évoquais tout à l'heure
de besoin qui ne serait pas satisfaits
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur ce
que j'ai pu faire
sur
Lafarge Alcatel
c'est laisser penser que l'étape
lorsqu'une entreprise est rachetée peut
intervenir aisément
il y a des grèves heureusement qu'il y
avait été pris sur certains nombre
d'opérations et puis il y en a d'autres
opérations qu'on ne peut pas empêcher
qui sont des des alliances qui se font
au départ on prétend que les intérêts
français je parle de Lafarge notamment
pour être préservés on s'aperçoit assez
vite que tel n'est pas le cas et
d'ailleurs tous les propos de d'Arnaud
Montebourg sont pas toujours
les miens mais il y a un point sur
lequel il intervenu de votre commission
qui est juste c'est que un certain
nombre de dirigeants d'entreprises ont
fait ces choix là ces dirigeants
d'entreprises français qui ont fait que
ils ont préféré aller vers une alliance
plutôt que avec une autre et rechercher
des financements pas pour eux-mêmes mais
mais moi pour leur entreprise de cette
façon
mais pour ce qui concerne général
électrique moi j'assume le choix que
j'ai fait je pense que ça aurait été
beaucoup plus difficile avec Alstom et
Siemens beaucoup plus difficile et pour
le nucléaire bon parce que si mal ça
avait perdu je pense une partie de de
son savoir-faire
et si c'était d'agi de de donner à
Siemens l'activité transport vous auriez
été le premier à me dire on a cédé aux
Allemands une activité essentielle pour
notre économie et aujourd'hui Alstom
Transport se parte plutôt bien
merci Madame Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président François
Hollande pour
votre déroulé extrêmement précis de ce
qui vous a conduit à prendre un certain
nombre de décisions pendant votre mandat
merci aussi pour avoir clarifié la
question des accords
politiques entre les Verts et les
socialistes qui ont animé notre
commission
à longueur de temps
parce que il y a effectivement les
accords de parties partis et ensuite il
y a les actes des présidents de la
République qui sont élus et vous avez
éclairci ce sujet dont je n'aurais pas
de questions à vous poser parce que je
j'aurais posé celle-ci au préalable sur
d'autres sujets je voulais revenir un
petit peu sur l'audition précédente de
votre prédécesseur
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a fait un certain
nombre de remarques
quand je dis remarque que c'est
voilà
je n'en dirai pas plus sur notamment
votre décision votre critique par
rapport au choix de fermeture de
l'installation de lag ou de Marcoule qui
considérait comme totalement
inopportunes voire irresponsable à ce
stade je pense que vous saurez nous
expliquer que ce n'était absolument pas
le cas je voulais revenir aussi sur
l'arène qui a été évoquée à plusieurs
reprises effectivement sous votre mandat
et vous l'avez dit la question de la
reine de la modification du tarif ou de
du changement des plafonds de se poser
pas réellement puisque les prix de
l'électricité étaient relativement
faibles et que ce dispositif ne mettait
pas finalement en danger la situation
financière de de l'entreprise EDF ce qui
n'est pas été le cas ensuite puisque
nous avons connu des périodes où les
tarifs de l'électricité étaient
extrêmement élevés et où la production
de nucléaire c'est avéré beaucoup plus
basse
donc est-ce que vous confirmez que dans
ces dans ces dans cette loi nomme et
dans la reine il y avait la possibilité
pour les gouvernements ce que vous
n'avez pas sûrement pas évoqué au regard
de la situation mais de revenir à la
fois sur le plafond puisque on était
dans des situations particulières et sur
le tarif puisque certains nombres
d'auditionnés précédents nous ont
confirmé que cette possibilité était
offerte par la loi et qu'elle n'avait
pas été mise en oeuvre quand la
situation pouvait pouvait l'imposer
votre prédécesseur nous a aussi
réaffirmé ce matin son engouement fort
pour
le marché la libéralisme la mise sur le
marché et finalement pour
ça ça réserve assez forte également sur
les situations de monopole puisqu'il
considèrent qu'elles se terminent
toujours très mal donc je voulais avoir
votre votre avis à la fois sur la
privatisation entre guillemets de
l'entreprise EDF entre 2004 et 2006 qui
s'est opéré et aujourd'hui la volonté de
du président de la République de
renationaliser
EDF et donc d'aller à l'encontre de ce
que préconisé le président
Sarkozy une dernière question également
sur qu'on n'a pas évoqué sur la mise en
concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques qui nous a je dis nous
parce que j'étais dans ce mandala qui
nous a occupé
longtemps et qui nous occupe d'ailleurs
encore puisque cette situation n'est pas
réglée donc le président Sarkozy a dit
ce matin avoir finalement un peu
anticipé la mise en demeure de la
commission europ éenne et que ma foi la
mise en concurrence c'était pas si grave
que cela en tout cas c'est ce que j'en
ai compris sauf que la mise en
concurrence est
[Musique]
n'est peut-être pas si grave lorsqu'elle
est
loyale alors que dans la situation des
concessions hydroélectriques la
concurrence était déloyale puisque je
rappelle que elle ouvrait notre marché
des concessions à tous les opérateurs
extérieurs à la France qu'il soit privé
ou public et que l'entreprise EDF elle
pouvait pas concourir à d'autres dans
d'autres pays puisque ils avaient
sécurisé pour un grand nombre d'entre
eux l'entrée des des entreprises
extérieures notamment en mettant dans
leur cahier des charges que
l'ouverture de leurs concession n'était
possible qu'aux entreprises qui
qui avait 75% de capitaux publics par
exemple ce qui on avait à appliquer la
même règle en France faisait traduisait
que EDF était le seul à pouvoir
concourir et donc garder les concessions
donc
la bataille avec la Commission
européenne continue à durer est-ce que
vous considérez que comme votre Ministre
Arnaud Montebourg nous l'a dit à la
dernière que finalement il y a il faut
faire fi de la Commission européenne et
attendre l'amende si elle vient un jour
puisque pour l'instant au bout des douze
ans nous n'avons pas remis en
concurrence un seul barrage
hydroélectrique et je trouve que c'est
une excellente nouvelle
si nous pouvons continuer ce serait bien
et je crois que j'en ai terminé pour
l'instant je vous remercie
bien je ne vois pas utiliser la
commission d'enquête pour refaire le
débat entre de tout avec Nicolas Sarkozy
ou savoir comment nous nous sommes
séparés au terme de son mandat et au
début du mien ou de ce qui nous a opposé
tout au long de notre vie politique et
l'autre je vous fais grâce de ce que
sont nos rapports et
je pense que dans l'idée même que nous
nous faisons de la République il est
plutôt préférable que nous puissions
nous en tenir à des considérations qui
justifient les respecte nous avons des
institutions et de ce que représente la
présidence de la République donc je vais
pas me livrer à une forme de petit
pugilat ou comme le disait une émission
de radio nous allons pas refaire le
match je pense qu'il a été fait c'est
terminé comme chacun c'est c'est
regrettable pour l'un satisfaisant
peut-être pour l'autre même si je ne
suis plus président moi non plus et je
devais pas moi-même ouvrir un débat de
cette ampleur avec mon successeur donc
voilà je fais grâce donc à la Commission
de de de de tout ce que je pourrais dire
sur sur les événements qui se sont
produits en 2012 mais néanmoins
n'appartient de
de relever que
l'accord avec les
socialistes et les vers les deux parties
c'est vrai
comporter des dispositions qui me
paraissaient pour la filière du clair
inquiétante
c'est pour ça que je ne les ai pas
repris je comprenais que il y avait des
négociations entreparties bon et qu'il
fallait on dit pour donner des
circonscriptions ouverts je ne sais pas
si c'était le but en soi mais pour créer
l'esprit d'union j'imagine qu'il fallait
donner certaines visibilité non mais
j'ai considéré qu'il y avait il y avait
trois points qui n'étaient pas
négociables il y avait
Marcoule et vous savez que ça a donné
lieu à des à des débats sur le box au
point que les gens qui ne sont pas quand
même bien spécialistes demandaient ce
que c'était que le box bon bah enfin
vous vous le savez donc il était pour
moi très clair qu'on ne pouvait pas
fermer cette filière si on nous l'avions
fermé c'était un risque pour Areva et
c'était aussi un problème
d'approvisionnement de nos centrales et
ça nous mettait en difficulté par
rapport à un projet que nous avions
toujours en tête qu'a Street pouvait
représenter de de retraitement bon donc
j'ai des pare-brise point là donc je
suis compromis pas que ça puisse revenir
dans dans la discussion si il y avait eu
un doute je leur ai exprimé mais à aucun
moment dans mon mandat il y a eu la
remise en cause de la filière boxe
puisque je n'avais même écarté
publiquement de la même manière pour lag
femme en ville ou pour le troisième
sujet qui était de les 24 centrales
j'avais écarté c'est c'est trois
trois sujets qui pouvaient devenir
autant de fantasmes pour Nicolas Sarkozy
en fait le débat
longtemps été que sur Fessenheim
avec une question qu'on a posé pourquoi
fait ce name pourquoi fermer une
centrale et même si dans nos vrais une
autre qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire sur
les vieilles centrales qu'est-ce que ça
a indiqué ça indiqué qu'à un moment nous
devions réfléchir collectivement à
prolonger les centrales existantes que
certaines de le pourraient pas et qu'il
aurait à ce moment-là était nécessaire
de les remplacer par des réacteurs de
nouvelles génération et ce qui est
intéressant puisque j'ai suivi partie de
ce caddie Nicolas Sarkozy c'est qu'il a
pu considérer que mon successeur n'était
pas responsable de la fermeture de
Fessenheim donc de ce point de vue là il
lui il lui en voulait pas mais il avait
pas de raison de lui en vouloir
d'ailleurs
mais il ne sait pas étonné ça réduit
normalement son coup qui est assez
facile généralement à stimuler donc il
aurait dû normalement exprimer avec coût
son opposition à la fermeture qui avait
été annoncée dans la loi de 12 réacteurs
dont les deux de Fessenheim il aurait dû
dire mais là voilà une mise en cause il
aurait eu tort parce que c'était pas une
mise en cause de la filière nucléaire en
tant que tel c'était l'idée que
justement il devait y avoir à terme des
renouvellements de de de centrale et les
plus vieilles pouvaient fermer quand
d'autres leraient à ouvrir peut-être sur
les mêmes lieux bah enfin deux poids de
mesure ça dépend effectivement quel est
le ressentiment que l'on a le plus au
fond de soi-même donc alors j'en ai
terminé avec mon prédécesseur et j'en
arrive
à la question
de la privatisation de DF qu'on peut y
revenir mais
surtout est-ce que ce que ça induit
parce que vous évoquez les barrages je
suis très attaché au barrage puisque
moi-même ayant été élus d'un département
où on avait des barrages
la privatisation d'EDF a été et la
libéralisation du marché mais la
privatisation du Def a été un élément
utilisé par la commission pour
nous obliger à mettre
les concessions à la concurrence c'était
ça l'argument l'argument principal à tel
point que durant notre mandat nous avons
été
conduits à réfléchir à la
nationalisation déjà def ou d'une partie
de DF
et que le gouvernement il vient aussi
pour justement retrouver sur les
activités de production une capacité
pour agir en dehors des des règles
souvent contraignantes pour pour le
marché
donc voilà quelle était l'avantage le
seul avantage quand même je dois le
reconnaître le seul avantage de de
l'ouverture c'est que c'est pour ça que
DF qui a consenti c'est que EDF a acheté
beaucoup d'entreprises en Europe
grâce à l'ouverture que Dave n'aurait
pas pu autrement acquérir
et donc il y avait il y avait cette
nécessité pour EDF de devenir la
première grande entreprise et on était
fier aussi que ça puisse être des temps
d'arbre pour la pour la production
d'énergie au niveau européen mais il y
avait cette contrainte qui pesait à
cause de la privatisation et aujourd'hui
je pense que ce que nous avons lutter
tous les gouvernements l'ont fait depuis
2012 nous avons lutté pour éviter que il
y ait
l'ouverture à la concurrence pour les
barrages mais nous n'avons pas modernisé
les barrages nous avons perdu des
capacités chacun sait qu'aujourd'hui sur
plusieurs installations il serait
possible de produire bien davantage donc
on a finalement
gelé si je puis dire pour les baraques
on les a comme ça sans que tu vas
arriver c'est vrai mais on les a pas
finalement mis en production autant
qu'il aurait fallu donc il faut en
sortir alors de votre question c'est de
dire est-ce qu'on peut discuter avec la
commission mais bien sûr qu'on peut
discuter avec la commission ça prend du
temps beaucoup de temps et ce qu'il faut
comme le propos certain dire on en a
rien à faire de la Commission et on va
attendre que les sanctions tombent très
franchement elle tomberont donc on doit
pas être dans cette position là qui est
une position perdante parce qu'à un
moment on peut pas tenir non il faut
aller négocier mais on négociera plus
facilement avec un EDF à 100% que on
pouvait le faire jusqu'à présent
sur la reine et la loi norme bon je
pense que là aussi
dans un contexte nouveau
principe qui sont posés sur le marché de
l'électricité
la Commission a montré certaines
compréhensions par rapport à notre thèse
sur le nucléaire et sur les contrats qui
peuvent être proposés je pense que la
reine doit être mis dans dans le dans le
lot de la négociation
merci monsieur le Président j'aurais une
petite question en de laisser la parole
circuler
on peut principal sur le rapport sur un
sujet aussi précis que celui de
l'énergie technique que celui de
l'électricité entre
votre vision du rapport entre le
politique et le technique sur sur des
sujets comme cela qui semble assez
déterminants et qui a largement occupé
les travaux et les auditions de notre
commission
illustrer j'ai envie de dire par
peut-être deux exemples qui sont qui se
révèlent au cours de votre mandat le
choix de nommer François Brotte à la
tête de RTL
pas sur un sujet personnel mais dans ce
qu'il représente la décision de mettre
un homme politique à la tête d'une
entreprise récente je le rappelle à
l'époque où vous le nommez mais qui est
une entreprise plutôt technique
et puis
le débat qui a existé là au fil des
auditions que nous avons conduites sur
tous les conseillers institutionnels qui
existent auprès des gouvernements de la
présidente de la République je pense au
commissaire à l'énergie atomique par
exemple et
à la régularité ou non d'un certain
nombre de réunions on a parlé du comité
à l'énergie atomique qui ont été
institués par la loi alors finalement
c'est une double question est-ce qu'il
faut instituer ce genre de réunion dans
la loi et si elles sont instituées
pourquoi elles ne sont pas tenues
voilà je pense la réponse peut être sur
l'un ou l'autre des registres
oui
l'énergie fait partie des sujets majeurs
pour notre pays et on l'a bien compris
et vous encore davantage en suivant les
travaux de la commission
c'est extrêmement technique et
ça suppose qu'ils connaissances y
compris quand on parle du mode de
fabrication des centrales de de
du cœur du réacteur de
du combustible lui-même tout ça fait que
même président de la République on doit
être relativement humble par rapport à
ces données là on a besoin donc de
conseils
mais peut-être y a-t-il trop de conseils
quand je dis pas trop de conseils trop
de structures qui viennent parce que on
savait que c'était tellement important
qu'il fallait se garantir quand même
et que aujourd'hui entre
CE1 entre
le Commissariat au commissaire qui est
un rôle un peu disons de Sage
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
maintenant liesse l'ISR l l'ISM qui
vient d'être libéré par vote jusqu'à
quand je ne sais pas mais voilà ça fait
beaucoup d'autorités beaucoup de de
d'expertise qui sont annoncées sans
compter ce que demande comme comme
décision les opérateurs auprès du
président de la République auprès du
gouvernement
comment faire donc je crois que il est
utile d'abord qu'il y ait des instances
indépendantes comme l'autorité comme
l'irsm qui permettent d'établir des des
des réalités incontestables ensuite on a
besoin d'avoir des des conseils qui
puissent être avec de nombreux avis de
nombreux experts capables de nous de
nous éclairer et puis aussi des
ingénieurs qui sont de haute qualité
vous me parlez de la nomination de pour
la présence de RTE RTE d'abord nous
avons fait en sorte que elles sortent du
giron d'EDF c'était une question qui
pouvait être posée fallait-il que RTE
soit dans dans EDF alors même que RTE
s'occupe de l'ensemble du réseau quel
que soit l'opérateur
et moi j'ai
voulu qu'on aille jusque là et
nous avons fait en sorte que la Caisse
des Dépôts puissent racheter une partie
du capital de RTE qui finalement renflé
aussi EDF après de savoir qui pouvait
être nommé à la tête de RTE François
broc exercé une fonction importante ici
c'était passionné depuis longtemps
faisant lui-même de l'entreprise pour
ces questions d'énergie
lorsqu'il a fait acte de candidature
j'ai pas considéré que parce qu'il avait
fait de la politique parce qu'il avait
occupé une fonction importante au
Parlement il était disqualifié pour être
nommé à la tête d'un organisme est-ce
que ça supposé que moi-même je veuille
avoir un oeil sur RTE jamais j'ai
considéré que la nomination de Brotte
motorisée comme président de la
République à lui faire la moindre
injonction et ensuite celui qui lui a
succédé mon ancien conseiller technique
à l'Elysée d'ancien conseiller de
Jean-Marc Ayrault monsieur piezavic et
Kiki qui qui lui-même agir en toute
indépendance et je pense que c'est très
utile d'avoir des justement des lieux où
une position peut-être défendue sans
qu'elle soit liée à une famille
politique et ça a été le cas même avec
François brut
merci Monsieur Loubet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la République François
Hollande merci pour cette audition
j'aurais deux sujets
à traiter avec vous essentiellement qui
ont été traités mais que je souhaiterais
approfondir le premier porte sur la
vente donc en 2014 de la branche énergie
d'Alstom en général électrique
honnêtement tout le monde peut
évidemment faire des erreurs mais je ne
comprends pas je suis très sincère avec
vous comment vous avez pu il y a
quelques minutes vous satisfaire de
cette vente
génère électrique c'était engagé lors de
la vente corrigez-moi si je me trompe à
créer si je me trompe pas 1500 emplois
ils en ont supprimé un millier génère
électrique a très probablement pillé la
technologie notamment de la turbine
Arabel c'est emparée de cette
technologie en l'achetant et aujourd'hui
et bien on retrouve la branche énergie
d'Alstom redevenir françaises maintenant
que la technologie est partie aux
États-Unis une technologie enviée dans
le monde entier Alstom c'est un leader
français dans les réseaux électriques
dans les turbines nucléaires mais aussi
hydraulique puisque
Alstom fournissait en termes de turbine
25% du marché mondial donc très
honnêtement je ne comprends pas comment
vous avez pu à l'instant vous satisfaire
de cette vente à général électrique il y
avait une solution qui n'était peut-être
pas parfaite avec Siemens effectivement
est-ce que cela n'aurait objectivement
pas limité les dégâts un minima avec une
entreprise
européenne en termes de perte de
savoir-faire outre-Atlantique
vers l'autre côté de l'Atlantique et en
termes de perte d'emploi industriels
ensuite je souhaiterais revenir
justement sur les propos de votre ancien
ministre Arnaud Montebourg dans le cadre
de cette vente de la branche énergie
d'Alstom est-ce que en réalité monsieur
le Président de la République vous
pouvez nous exposer les motifs pour
lesquels la direction d'Alstom a
souhaité vendre sa branche énergie parce
que Arnaud Montebourg a évoqué la
carcération effectivement de ce fameux
cadre d'Alstom Monsieur Pierre ruchi
pour ne pas le nommer dans des
conditions particulières il a d'ailleurs
regretté les défaillances de
l'intelligence économique française il a
également
dénoncé un chantage finalement qui a eu
lieu de la part des des renseignements
américains dans cette affaire
nous laissant entendre finalement que la
vente d'Alstom de la branche énergie
d'Alstom à l'Américain général
électrique c'était jouer ailleurs que un
simple accord commercial finalement
est-ce que ça n'a pas été un bras de
votre puissance française et les
États-Unis et un bras de fer que nous
vous avez perdu finalement donc que
pensez-vous de cette déclaration
d'Arnaud Montebourg qui affirme que
l'espionnage américain a lourdement
pesée dans la volonté de la vente de la
branche énergie d'Alstom à General
Electric bien évidemment il y avait un
moyen vous en avez parlé de bloquer
cette vente c'était de recourir au
décret Villepin qui avait été renforcé
sous votre présidence d'ailleurs mais
encore fallait-il l'utiliser par Arnaud
Montebourg le deuxième sujet que je
souhaiterais traiter avec vous c'est le
fameux seuil donc des 50% de production
nucléaire dans le mix électrique
français je ne comprends pas alors vous
nous avez dit effectivement qu'il y
avait toute une multitude de conseils
techniques d'entités qui apportait leur
expertise etc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire quel est justement l'entité
l'organisme qui vous a convaincu qui
vous a apporté l'expertise scientifique
selon laquelle ses 50 10% étaient
objectivement réalisable parce que
évidemment ces 50% sont issus d'un
accord politiqueien entre les
socialistes et les écologistes mais sur
quelle base scientifique est-ce que vous
vous êtes fondé pour prendre cette
décision majeure dont aujourd'hui nous
payons les conséquences fort
heureusement la le seuil vient de sauter
dans le cadre de l'examen pour le projet
de loi de relance du nucléaire que nous
venons que nous sommes en train
d'étudier
j'ajoute effectivement vous n'avez pas
fermé de centrale nucléaires du vent
durant votre quinquennat c'est tout à
fait vrai bien évidemment seulement en
créant ce seuil de 50%
vous avez finalement reporté la
fermeture d'une centrale nucléaire à
votre successeur Emmanuel Macron qui
donc a finalement appliqué votre loi il
aurait pu revenir dessus donc il en a
effectivement une part de responsabilité
mais il a piqué malgré tout la loi de
votre majorité socialiste comment
rationnellement monsieur le Président de
la République pensez-vous effectivement
qu'avec un mix électrique à 50% de
production nucléaire on parviendrait à
horizon 2025 quand vous étiez en
fonction à horizon 2025 de d'assurer la
sécurité d'approvisionnement électrique
du pays est-ce que vous n'aviez pas
quand même anticipé des pénuries
possibles qu'elles étaient les les
leviers que vous pouviez trouver vous
savez je suis élu de Saint-Avold
où on vient de relancer une centrale à
charbon 600 mégawatts pour compenser la
fermeture et bien de 1800 MW de
production électrique nucléaire de
Fessenheim donc effectivement comment
rationnellement est-ce que vous comptiez
garantir la sécurité d'approvisionnement
électrique d'une du pays et enfin est-ce
que vous n'estimez pas finalement que
ces 50% d'énergie renouvelables dans le
mix électrique en tout cas à l'état de
connaissance actuelle scientifique et
technique et bien c'était une lubie vous
savez il y a eu un rapport de la Cour
des comptes peu après votre quinquennat
qui dénonçait la gabegie la gabegie des
ENR des énergies renouvelables hors
hydrauliques bien évidemment en termes
de subventions publiques si je me trompe
pas c'est plus de 120 milliards d'euros
d'engagement de l'état de soutien public
dans des contrats avant 2017 avant 2017
pour financer les éoliennes et les
panneaux photovoltaïques dans notre pays
120 milliards d'euros c'est à peu près
le montant que nous a coûté la
construction du parc nucléaire français
donc 120 milliards d'euros pour l'éolien
et le photovoltaïque qui finalement ne
parviennent même pas à nous assurer
allez 20% de la production électrique
française et encore quand il y a du vent
et du soleil donc concrètement ce que
vous ne pensez pas avec du recul que
c'était un phénomène de mode qui
aujourd'hui n'a plus raison d'être merci
pour vos retours merci Monsieur vos
trois minutes me semble toujours
excessivement longue mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la question de la
relativité qui se pose dans ce cas là ce
président bah je me suis demandé on vous
écoutant si vous m'aviez vous-même
entendu parce que j'ai essayé de
convaincre avec des faits que nous
avions perdu aucune capacité et vous me
parlez vous me parlez là de la centrale
de Saint-Avold qui réouvre parce que
nous aurions fermé Fessenheim c'est pas
la raison je vous ai expliqué que il y
avait eu
130 tt qui n'avaient pas été produit
fait cela mettant 10 terawater et que
c'est 130 qui n'ont pas été produits
pour toutes les raisons que je vais pas
reprendre ici et vous me dites là-bas
c'est terrible on ouvre la centrale de
symbole par ailleurs vous électeurs
seront ravis d'apprendre que vous voulez
la fermer le plus rapidement possible
parce que je pense aussi nécessaire mais
donc je veux pas ici reprendre tous les
arguments nous n'avons perdu aucun
terawater durant toute notre
présidence nous avons fait en sorte de
garder le parc tel qu'il était tout en
le redoublant l'améliorant le
modernisant etc bon deuxièmement vous
nous dites
les 50% d'ailleurs
que je ne veux pas accablé l'accord VRPs
que je ne l'ai pas repris donc il va
falloir un moment que vous cessiez de
dire c'est l'accord je ne l'ai pas
repris et si je puis dire les 50%, je
les avais moi-même fichiers avant qu'il
accorde vers PS au lendemain de
Fukushima non pas pour dire que ça
allait se faire tout de suite mais pour
dire qu'il fallait délaisser du temps
j'avais évoqué 2025 en sachant que ça
pouvait être un horizon qui pouvait être
poussé et pour le reste d'accord vers pS
Les 24 centrales n'ont jamais été repris
par mois par mois en tant que candidat
mais surtout c'est le plus important par
mois en tant que président alors on peut
continuer à alimenter ce fantasme mais
débarrassez-vous-en assez rapidement
parce que les fantasmes de généralement
ne conduisent pas des bonnes actions
donc deuxièmement vous me dites ce que
j'ai entendu ça aussi c'est pas
simplement dans votre bouche est-ce
qu'il y a eu une étude d'impact avant
les 50%
mais
dans l'opposition c'est déjà difficile
de faire des
des études et au gouvernement peut-être
plus facilement encore que
sans tomber dans la polémique quand
Emmanuel Macron il avait bien le droit
annonce la retraite à 65 ans il a fait
des études d'impact à ma connaissance il
avait fait une étude d'impact il aurait
peut-être mesuré les effets donc on ne
peut pas quand on est dans l'opposition
faire des études d'impact donc ce qu'on
peut faire c'est notre devoir même c'est
on n'a pas les tous les éléments pour
pour y parvenir mais on doit travailler
avec tous les experts qui sont dans
l'opposition capable de nous fournir des
informations et c'est ce que nous avons
fait et donc j'ai retenu tout ce qui
m'était dit avec l'objectif de de fixer
un objectif politique car c'était un
objectif politique ensuite comment cet
objectif politique se traduit dans la
réalité c'était ça la conséquent et bien
ça se traduit dans la réalité en
espérant faire monter les renouvelables
en espérant que la consommation
électrique allait augmenter pour
permettre que nous puissions euh faire
baisser la part du nucléaire et de faire
en sorte aussi que nous puissions faire
de la sobriété énergétique voilà ce que
nous avions fixé comme objectif et je
m'y suis tenu est-ce que j'ai reporté
sur mon successeur oui la fermeture de
faisan je dois dire que mon successeur
des et la reprise mais mais elle était
suffisamment engagée je m'accepte tout à
fait la responsabilité après il a voulu
lui-même annoncé qu'il pouvait fermer
d'autres centrales ce qui pouvait se
concevoir dans une logique de
renouvellement du parc aujourd'hui dans
un contexte différent avec la guerre en
Ukraine il a été décidé de lancer un
programme je pense que c'est juste un
programme de construction de centrales
de PR2 dans une série ce que je crois
être là aussi préférable et qui vont se
substituer progressivement à des
centrales qui certaines seront
maintenues et d'autres seront supprimés
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur ce
sujet là sur le sujet général électrique
Alstom et général écrit n'était pas du
tout une entreprise inconnue en France
c'était pas une entreprise extérieure
même si elle avait des capitaux des
capitaux américains c'était une
entreprise qui avait des emplois en
France qui travaillaient avec la France
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs et notamment
sur la question du nucléaire c'était pas
des personnes que nous voulions pas
rencontrer les ingénieurs travaillaient
avec
général électrique ensuite
général-lectique a été prétenté par le
groupe Alstom propriétaire de leur
entreprise
on sentait bien que c'était leur
préférence
j'ai fait étudier une seconde option qui
était l'option Siemens qui ne doit
rassurer pas je l'ai déjà ici indiqué
qu'il nous rassurait pas parce qu'elle
n'avait pas forcément les compétences
que nous voulions en matière de
nucléaire et qu'elle voulait absorber
tout le groupe Alstom donc on a préféré
prendre général électrique il s'est
trouvé que Général Electric qui était
plutôt
en bonne santé quand elle s'est
présentée à nous a connu une défaillance
ensuite bon sur les emplois d'avions
fixé une règle pénalité que si les
emplois les 1000 emplois n'étaient pas
créés il y aurait une sanction
financière d'ailleurs ça a été honoré
alors après vous parlez de d'espionnage
dans la très franchement qu'il y ait eu
aux États-Unis une tentative peut-être
d'intimidation c'est tout à fait
possible enfin moi je n'ai pas été du
tout dans jeunes séquelles négociation
discussions échange d'informations avec
les États-Unis la faute qu'on soit
absolument clair d'ailleurs pour être
tout à fait puisque on est devant une
commission d'enquête sur ces affaires là
je n'ai reçu aucun appel ni des
dirigeants américains en l'occurrence
c'était Obama ni pour Siemens de Madame
Merkel rien
donc on n'a pas pris une décision sous
influence de qui que ce soit cette
édition qui a été prise en fonction de
ce que l'on croyait ce qu'on peut croire
encore être l'intérêt de d'alsom
maintenant ça s'est passé
dans un contexte arrive à d'autres
contextes je trouve que c'est bien qu'on
est plus reprendre ce qu'on avait
peut-être cédé et qui n'aurait pas dû
l'être aussi on a vu une autre direction
la seule option qui a été d'ailleurs
regardée était la nationalisation
plus récente d'Alstom ça c'était
l'option d'ailleurs à nos Montois a dû
vous le dire ça faisait partie de ce
qu'on avait à un moment mis comme close
si devait y avoir une défaillance
fallait y avoir les moyens de le faire
mais on avait les moyens de le faire
maintenant je ne sais pas si vous êtes
teneur de cette économie là mais enfin
chaque fois qu'il y a un problème
d'entreprise il faut nationaliser
l'entreprise en question on va retrouver
un secteur public assez assez fort dans
d'autres pays
merci je me permets encore une question
qui est finalement une question sur la
prospective parce qu'on sent bien que ce
cœur
des difficultés qui sont celles que l'on
connaît et au cœur de ce qui définit une
stratégie énergétique il y a le sujet de
la prospective et on comprend au fil des
auditions que nous avons menées qu'il y
a eu peut-être eu
on ira toussautement des de la
prospective française en matière
énergétique et dans la construction
successive des scénarios
ce qu'on observe aussi c'est un
glissement d'une expertise de l'État
vers des antennes de l'État et puis
ensuite peut-être
des batailles entre antenne de l'État
pour savoir qui a le bon scénario
pour finir aujourd'hui dans une
situation où on demande aux transporteur
d'électricité de produire un scénario de
consommation d'énergie
ce qui ne manque pas d'un peu
d'incohérence comment est-ce que vous
abordiez ce sujet notamment avec
l'action forte qui a été celle de vos
gouvernements successifs autour de la
décarbonation avec
stratégie nationale bas carbone et puis
ce qui a présenté
une une révolution pour pour certains en
tout cas des personnes que nous avons
auditionné le passage du facteur 4 au 0
émission net que je vous avoue avoir un
peu de mal à comprendre en tout cas pour
ma part dans l'impact que ça sur le
réseau puisque enfin sur le système
énergétique puisque l'impact me semble
être avant tout une accélération et pas
un changement de nature quoi alors que
on essaye parfois de faire passer un
changement de nature du système pour un
peu plus que une simple accélération
ce qui est compliqué avec la prévision
c'est de prévoir
bon je vais en donner quelques
illustrations
2008 arrive une crise financière majeure
avec une crise économique considérable
qui qui conduit une croissance très
ralentie même une récession en 2009
donc l'idée qui s'installe c'est qu'on
est dans un cycle long de
production faible et donc que de
consommation d'énergie également faible
et donc les les prévisionnistes partent
de ce qu'ils connaissent
sans forcément savoir ce qui va se
produire après
le choc d'une épreuve ou d'une crise
2015 2015 on est déjà dans un autre
contexte d'abord
la question climatique est devenue
première
l'accord de Paris va en être une
démonstration et deuxièmement parce que
il y a la nécessité de de passer plus
vite qu'on avait cru à la transition et
notamment par rapport aux énergies
fossiles alors même que les énergies
fossiles sont d'un coup très faible
le gaz et regardez comme l'énergie de
demain
dans ce moment là
et puis arrive troisième épisode si je
puis dire la guerre du crâne qui est un
autre choc et qui nous conduit à aller
encore plus loin le gaz est une énergie
qui restera présente mais mais à des
niveaux qui seront de plus en plus
faibles en tout cas en France et
deuxièmement on est maintenant vers une
projection d'une consommation électrique
forte forte à cause des des véhicules
électriques des Data etc donc voilà
pourquoi
il faut essayer d'avoir plusieurs
scénarios de prévision je parle pas de
scénario simplement d'action comme le
RTE on a établi avoir plusieurs
scénarios et essayer de coller le mieux
à ce que l'on peut vouloir et prévoir
mais ce qui compte je pense en France ça
serait d'avoir un outil réel de
planification alors regardez ce qui
existe dans notre domaine administratif
je crois qu'il y a un commissariat au
Plan
il y a un commissaire en tout cas voilà
il y a un secrétaire général
à la planification qui ne relève pas
d'ailleurs du commissaire au Plan à ma
connaissance
et puis il y a RTE et puis il y en a
d'autres agents qui travaillent à
prospective
nous aurions surement besoin d'avoir un
lieu un lieu connu comme le plan a été
longtemps ou
à la fois la capacité de projection
les options qui soient ouvertes pour les
décideurs et une vision longue tout à
l'heure on a conclu j'ai conclu mon
propos en parlant de recherche de
consensus ce que la planification
pouvait autoriser et bien c'est ça qui
nous manque après on se trompera
toujours sur les prévisions il y en a
avec qui annoncé
la décroissance elle ne s'est pas
produite il y en a qui a annoncé
au contraire des périodes glorieuses
elles sont pas arrivées donc on se
trompera toujours sur les scénarios
économiques mais ce qui compte c'est pas
les scénarios iconiques seulement c'est
ce que nous voulons nous pour notre pays
qu'est-ce que nous voulons avoir comme
comme bilan énergétique qu'est-ce que
nous voulons favoriser comme industrie
comment vous voulons nous organiser sur
le plan territorial donc c'est pour ça
que je crois qu'il nous manque pas
simplement des outils de prévision mais
des outils de planification
merci ce qui est encore des questions
madame pouire
merci président monsieur le Président
Hollande tout d'abord excusé pour mon
départ momentané suite
à ce qui se passait en séance donc je
pense que vous avez eu l'occasion de
revenir sur
le choix qui a été fait de d'imposer un
plafond de 63
gigawatts de puissance installée
néanmoins comme vous l'avez dit c'est
contraignant c'est un objectif un
engagement contraignant contrairement
effectivement
à l'objectif des 50% du mix qui était un
objectif qui effectivement a pu évoluer
dans le temps et comme je pense que ici
on ne s'attache pas forcément à avoir
100% nucléaire ni 100% de NR et
d'ailleurs que c'est assez
fatigant pour les politiques de devoir
justifier que l'on veuille un mix
diversifié et pourtant c'est la
recommandation même de fatigue pas mal
de de l'agence internationale de
l'électricité je voulais quand même
revenir sur le fait qu'à ce moment-là on
pouvait envisager que l'électrification
des usages à les mener une plus grande
demande en électricité et aujourd'hui on
a aussi la
l'idée de produire de l'hydrogène à
partir du nucléaire et donc l'idée
arrive que peut-être nous devrions être
en surcapacité de production nucléaire
donc comme on en est à l'heure de la
prospective voilà aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous remettriez un plafond si vous étiez
en fonction est-ce que vous mettriez un
plafond d'énergie de puissance nucléaire
installée ou est-ce que vous pensez
différemment
merci pour cette question
du sèche me répéter
est-ce que ce plafond nous a empêché
de produire de l'électricité depuis
qu'il a été installé même si demain il
sera supprimé est-ce que ça a été pour
EDF une renonciation à produire non rien
n'a été
empêché par ce plafond et si je voulais
rappeler les chiffres aujourd'hui on est
à 41 gigawatts de
on le sera pas toujours mais quand bien
même on aurait tout notre parc à plein
régime on est toujours et qu'en
Flamanville va venir
on sera encore en dessous du plafond
puisque le plafond avait été fait avec
Flamanville je rappelle que flamophile
est toujours pas en activité donc ce
plafond là nous limite pas il ne nous
empêche pas et nous contraint pas c'est
pour ça qu'il me paraissait beaucoup
plus opératoires que les 50% qui étaient
un objectif politique celui-là il nous
permettait de dire on va avoir la pleine
capacité de notre industrie nucléaire et
puis ensuite on va pouvoir parallèlement
développer le renouvelable alors il peut
se produire comme vous le dites que la
consommation électrique soit encore plus
forte que le besoin de nous débarrasser
complètement des énergies fossiles de
conduisent encore accéléré et donc c'est
ce qui justifie à la fois la
prolongation des centrales ce que j'ai
moi-même autorisé durant mon mandat 50
ans peut-être demain 60 ans et
gouvernement vient de le décider de de
lancer un programme de construction de
centrales nucléaire dont on verra
j'espère la mise en fonctionnement pas
avant 2035 2040 dans le meilleur des cas
parce qu'on sait que c'est long c'est au
moins 10 ans pour construire une
centrale ça a toujours été 10 ans la
dernière central qui avait été
construite dans dans la série donc du
programme
Messmer Mitterrand ils sont plus là ils
me permettront de les associer pour une
fois Messmer Mitterrand et bien la
dernière centrale elle est elle est
décidée en 92 et elle se met en service
en 2002 donc ça sera long donc c'est
pour ça qu'il est tout à fait nécessaire
de prolonger les centrales autant qu'on
le peut et on aura nécessairement quand
on aura les nouvelles centrales à ce
qu'il se substituent aux anciens
réacteurs parce que toutes les centrales
qui seront à 50 ans 60 ans et avec une
autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui qui
sera de plus en plus vigilante et on
voit les incidents d'aujourd'hui il nous
dira cette autorité de sûreté vous ne
pouvez pas prolonger donc il va falloir
qu'on
remplace les vieilles centrales par ces
nouveaux réacteurs mais l'avantage c'est
que ces réacteurs seront plus puissants
d'où l'enjeu aussi des plus petits
réacteurs des SMS que j'ai moi-même
conduit à prolonger les recherches pour
qu'on puisse les sortir si il apparaît
que tout en ayant développé le
renouvelable tout en ayant prolongé les
centrales que on a tel besoin de de
production électrique pour satisfaire
une consommation qui serait
tout à fait élevé on verra ce qu'on fait
de c'est ça qui aurait été intéressant
on verra ce qu'on ce qu'on ferait du
plafond moi ce qui me paraît dommageable
c'est qu'on supprime un plafond alors
que il n'était nullement une contrainte
mais plutôt une façon de dire voilà on a
une capacité de nucléaire et on va faire
du renouvelable pour compléter autant
qu'il sera possible et de la sobriété
énergétique bon voilà pourquoi je pense
que c'était pas utile de supprimer le
plafond après que on veuille pas retenir
le chiffre 50% même si la première
ministre dit il y aura finalement à la
fin ça contrôleur qu'importe ça c'est le
résultat mais le plafond je pense que
c'était une une bonne indication de la
une utilisation de nos capacités de
production et comme vous l'avez très
bien dit enfin jusqu'à
20 20 est une année particulière de
jusqu'à 2019 on exportait du de
l'électricité nucléaire ça voulait dire
quoi exporter de l'électricité du clair
ça voulait dire que on avait une
capacité nucléaire qui excédait
d'électricité qui excédait nos propres
besoins donc
ça prouvait bien que on n'était pas en
contrainte si on avait été en contrainte
on aurait pas exporté bah voilà donc
maintenant on exporte plus mais on peut
plus produire autant qu'on le voudrait
non pas parce que il y aurait eu une
décision en 2012 mais parce que on est
devant ces incidents qui j'espère
disparaîtront le plus rapidement
possible mais ça nous prendra il faut
quand même être clair ça va nous prendre
deux ou trois ans avant qu'on puisse
avoir cette pleine capacité et donc le
plafond il sera pas atteint
si vous me permettez
est-ce que cette double contrainte
même si une légale et l'autre est une
indication politique du plafond et de la
part de nucléaire dans le mix électrique
a été réellement comprise de la façon
dont vous l'expliquez aujourd'hui à
l'époque où ça a été voté ou est-ce que
dans les tâtonnement que nous avons pu
observer au cours des auditions
successives que nous avons menées ne
s'est pas progressivement construit une
justification
[Musique]
a postériori de d'une décision qui était
politiquement différente et qui avait un
autre sens à l'époque où elle a été
prise
je vais vous répondre politiquement je
pense que si je n'avais pas
pris la décision comme candidat de dire
voilà nous allons préserver l'industrie
nucléaire nous allons faire en sorte que
elle représente à terme sans préciser
finalement toujours
l'horizon à terme 50%, je pense que le
risque à ce moment-là dans l'état
d'esprit de l'opinion
UTT de pousser un candidat qui n'aurait
pas été moi qui n'aurait pas été non
plus mon prédécesseur à aller beaucoup
plus loin dans l'abandon du nucléaire
heureusement que j'ai fixé cette cette
perspective qui a qui a convaincu les
Français j'en suis sûr que c'était la
perspective la plus raisonnable du
nucléaire du renouvelable le tout
nucléaire tout à l'heure
j'entendais Nicolas Sark vidéo
le nucléaire j'aurais dit le nucléaire
est un modèle dépassé non c'est le tout
nucléaire qui était un modèle dépassé
pas le nucléaire c'est le tout nucléaire
qui est un modèle dépassé
deuxièmement ce que je voulais c'était
que à travers cette affirmation
politique nous comprenions bien qu'on
avait besoin du nucléaire qu'on aurait
toujours besoin d'une éclairer pour très
longtemps
mais que nous avions aussi besoin de
développer une industrie du renouvelable
et que ça c'était l'enjeu majeur et je
vous ai dit mon regret c'est qu'on n'a
pas pu réaliser l'objectif que j'avais
fixé finalement c'est pas les 50 % qui
m'ont posé un problème c'est le fait que
le renouvelable n'allait pas aussi vite
que je leur ai souhaité
merci beaucoup
monsieur je vous laisse la parole
je vous remercie monsieur le
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
de la République et comme c'est c'est
notre dernière audition j'en profite si
vous le permettez pour vous remercier
monsieur le Président de la commission
d'enquête pour l'initiative de cette
commission d'enquête pour la rigueur la
qualité de votre président des auditions
que nous avons pu mener avec l'appui
indispensable et précieux de nos
administratrices et de tous les services
de l'Assemblée nationale il m'incombe
donc désormais de faire de ses 150
heures d'audition de ces 5000 pages de
documents collectés et des autres
auditions techniques que j'ai pu mener
d'en faire une synthèse j'espère aussi
fidèle que possible et d'en tirer les
propositions les plus utiles les plus
nécessaires à notre modèle énergétique
et à notre pays je vous remercie
alors merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur je m'associe aux
remerciements qui sont les vôtres
monsieur le Président de la République
excusez peut-être ce moment un peu de
solennité qui nous est interne et propre
c'est vrai que je pense que
le télescope de l'actualité du jour
correspond aussi à un autre télescopage
qui a été celui des travaux de notre
commission dont on a souhaité qu'il
puisse aller au fond qui puisse servir à
éclairer la décision futures qui seront
à venir à une époque où dans l'actualité
le Parlement n'était pas forcément à sa
plus haute gloire en matière de qualité
des débats qui se tenaient dans
l'hémicycle et j'espère que les travaux
que nous avons menés que vous allez
continuer à poursuivre monsieur le
rapporteur dans la rédaction de votre
rapport
permettront de redonner aussi un peu de
noblesse aux politiques un peu de
noblesse au débat politique et un peu de
sens à notre travail mais en conclusion
de ces je vous laisserai la parole
monsieur le Président de la République
non sans avoir encore une dernière fois
formuler mes remerciements très sincères
que nous partageions ou pas les mêmes
options politiques vous avez accepté de
venir ici alors que comme votre
prédécesseur la Constitution ne vous y
contraignez pas mais ça nous est
forcément utile en tant que
parlementaire de pouvoir comprendre
comment au plus haut niveau de l'État
ces intérêts stratégiques sont perçus
traiter et ensuite comment il conduisent
à la production de décision politique en
fonction d'engagement pris en fonction
de débats tel qu'ils ont lieu dans la
société à un moment donné et cet
éclairage nous permettra je l'espère de
construire au niveau du Parlement les
choix politiques futurs dans cette
question stratégique voilà donc je tiens
à vous remercier monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commission d'enquête pour l'engagement
et le travail précis qui a été le vôtre
aussi et monsieur le Président de la
République si vous voulez ajouter un mot
pour conclure
je vous laisse cette honneur
s'il me reste dans quelques minutes
avant que des votes importants soient
faits je vais les utiliser donc pas pour
vous retenir et vous empêcher et pour
vous empêcher de faire votre votre
devoir dans un sens ou dans un autre
mais comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président si je suis venu c'est pas par
obligation je vais toute liberté pour ne
pas répondre à votre invitation en
prétextant la séparation des pouvoirs si
je suis venu c'est pas non plus pour
simplement rendre compte de ce que
j'avais fait
le ministre le enfin les ministres que
j'avais nommé que vous avez auditionné
Premier ministre pouvait le faire tout à
fait à ma place si je suis venu c'est
parce que j'ai considéré que votre
commission d'enquête qui bien sûr
portait sur le passé pouvait être aussi
un élément qui permettait de projeter
d'autres pays vers ce qu'est son avenir
énergétique et notamment par rapport à
la production d'électricité et donc
c'est que je pense que votre commission
au delà de ce que vous aurez à dire sur
les différents responsables qui se sont
succédés et sur les choix qui ont pu
être fait c'est d'aboutir à cette
conclusion c'est de faire qu'il puisse y
avoir la Morse d'un consensus possible
et d'une planification de nos choix
par ailleurs
avant de venir vers vous j'ai quand même
lu les comptes rendus d'audition
je vous vraiment je vous félicite pour
je sais pas si vous y avez tous
participé mais pour le temps que vous
avez consacré et pour la qualité des
échanges qui ont été ici
relevés et aussi pour avoir fait
comprendre à tous vos invités qui eux
quelquefois venaient parce qu'ils y
étaient obligés et qu'il devait même
prêter serment pour être sûr qu'il
disait vraiment la vérité mais ce qui
est quelquefois difficile à établir mais
c'est qu'ils ont tous fait l'effort de
de venir présenter pas simplement leur
choix mais aussi leur vision de ce
qu'est l'énergie dans notre pays et
c'est pour ça que le Parlement dont vous
avez dit qu'il ne l'est pas toujours la
meilleure image là il peut donner son
meilleur rôle c'est à dire bien sûr de
contrôler d'évaluer et de proposer et
tout à l'heure on évoquait qui auprès du
président de la République peut avoir
cette capacité à donner des éléments
précis sur ce que peuvent être des choix
et bien je ne sais pas qui sont les
décideurs dans les années qui viennent
mais je leur conseillerais de lire les
travaux de votre commission
merci monsieur le Président de la
République merci mesdames messieurs les
membres de cette commission merci
monsieur le rapporteur et C'est non sans
une certaine émotion que je clos donc
cette dernière audition de notre
commission d'enquête bonne fin de
journée à tous